Hello, everyone, and before today's show, I have incredibly exciting news for you about a live show. On Friday the 4th of September, Dominic and I will be at the South Bank to do something that we have not done before. So you will be the first people to hear it. We are telling the story of what is the ultimate Victorian adventure. The date is 1868. The location is Abbasic. And the Emperor of Abyssinia has been writing letters to Queen Victoria, who rather rudely has not replied to them.
大家好，在今天的节目开始之前，我有一个关于现场演出的激动人心的消息要告诉大家。9月4日星期五，多米尼克和我将在南岸做一件我们从未做过的事情。所以你们将是第一批听到这个消息的人。我们将讲述一个终极维多利亚时代的冒险故事。时间是1868年。地点是阿比西尼亚。阿比西尼亚皇帝一直在给维多利亚女王写信，但女王非常粗鲁地没有回复。
So the Emperor of Abyssinia, annoyed about this, has kidnapped a number of British subjects. In response, Britain sends an expedition to rescue the captives. And it is no exaggeration to say, it is massive. On this expedition, 13,000 soldiers, 40,000 animals, including 44 elephants, and the British even put down a railway line to transport everything. It's an incredible story full of jaw-dropping events, ludicrous characters, lots of moustaches, lots of general Victorian shenanigans. and as I say, it is the first time that we have ever done it on The Rest is History. I don't want to blow our trumpet, but I think it's going to be an absolute Restless History classic. So if you want to get a ticket for the ultimate Victorian adventure at the South Bank in London,
因此，阿比西尼亚皇帝对此感到恼火，绑架了一些英国臣民。作为回应，英国派遣了一支远征军去营救俘虏。毫不夸张地说，这支队伍规模庞大。在这支远征军中，有13000名士兵，40000头动物，包括44头大象，英国人甚至铺设了一条铁路线来运输所有物资。这是一个令人难以置信的故事，充满了令人瞠目结舌的事件、荒谬的人物、大量的胡子，以及许多典型的维多利亚时代的恶作剧。正如我所说，这是我们第一次在《历史的余味》中这样做。我不想自吹自擂，但我认为这将是《历史的余味》的绝对经典。所以，如果你想在伦敦南岸获得一张终极维多利亚时代冒险的门票，
on Friday the 4th of September, you know where to go. The Rest is History.com. Great news. The federal EV rebate is back. Eligible customers get up to $5,000 with the federal EVAP rebate on select 2027-volt and 2026 Equinox EV models. Visit your local Chevrolet dealer today for more details. Get your tickets now for the dog stars. It's no surprise how fast civilization can disappear.
就在9月4日星期五，你知道该去哪里。TheRestisHistory.com。好消息。联邦电动汽车退税回归了。符合条件的客户在购买指定的2027款Volt和2026款Equinox EV车型时，可获得最高5000美元的联邦电动汽车退税。请立即访问您当地的雪佛兰经销商了解更多详情。立即购买《狗星》的门票。文明消失得如此之快，这并不令人惊讶。
Go! Out there, is kill or be killed. Jacob Alorty. There are people out there? They need our help. Josh Berlin. Shoot first and inquire afterwards. Margaret Quali.
走！在那外面，不是你死就是我亡。雅各布·阿洛蒂。外面有人吗？他们需要我们的帮助。乔什·伯林。先开枪，再询问。玛格丽特·库里。
Okay, tough guy. And Guy Pearce. Arm up! The Dog Stars, directed by Ridley Scott. In theaters, August 28th. Get tickets now. The affairs being thus prepared, and forces in readiness both without and within the realm,
好吧，硬汉。还有盖·皮尔斯。武装起来！《狗星》，雷德利·斯科特导演。8月28日上映。立即购票。既然事务已经准备就绪，王国之内外的力量也已就位，
then shall it be time to set the six gentlemen to work. Taking order that on the accomplishing of their design, I may be suddenly transported out of this place, and that all your forces in the same time beyond the field to meet me. as we await the arrival of the foreign aid, which then must be hastened with all diligence. So that is an extract from one of the most consequential letters in all British history. It was written on behalf of Mary Queen of Scots, brought up, educated in France, hence the accent. And it was written actually by one of her secretaries.
那么就是让那六位绅士开始行动的时候了。下令在他们的计划完成后，我能被突然从这个地方转移出去，并且你们所有的力量在同一时间越过田野来迎接我。当我们等待外国援助的到来时，必须以最勤勉的态度加快速度。这就是英国历史上最具影响力的信件之一的摘录。它是代表苏格兰女王玛丽写的，她在法国长大、受教育，所以有那种口音。而且它实际上是由她的一位秘书写的。
And it was written on the evening of the 17th of July, 1586. It was then transcribed into a secret code, and then early the following morning, it was sent to a young Catholic gentleman whose name was Anthony Babington. And at the end of the letter, there was a PS which read as follows, fail not to burn this present quickly. And you can understand why somebody put that PS in there, because what is in this letter could not be more sensitive, more incendiary. Because what Mary is doing there, Tom, she's giving the green light, isn't she, to something that has been mooted for so many years, the operation to overthrow her cousin, Queen Elizabeth of England and take the throne herself. Yes, and it is projected that this will be combined with an armed uprising in England itself and that this uprising will release,
它写于1586年7月17日晚上。随后它被转录成秘密代码，并在第二天清晨被送给了一位名叫安东尼·巴宾顿的年轻天主教绅士。在信的末尾，有一个附言，内容如下：务必尽快烧掉这封信。你可以理解为什么有人会加上那个附言，因为这封信里的内容再敏感、再具煽动性不过了。因为玛丽在那里所做的事情，汤姆，她是在为多年来一直被讨论的事情开绿灯，不是吗？即推翻她的表妹、英格兰女王伊丽莎白并亲自夺取王位的行动。是的，而且预计这将与英格兰本土的武装起义相结合，并且这次起义将释放，
Mary from her captivity. It will be coordinated with an invasion from France. And Elizabeth's fate, Mary does not explicitly say what this is to be, but her meaning is clear because 17 days earlier, this young Catholic gentleman, Anthony Babington, had written a letter to Mary and had proposed in this letter, the assassination of the woman he described as the usurper. In other words, Elizabeth. So he'd written, there be six noble gentlemen, all my private friends, who for the zeal they bear to the Catholic cause and your majesty's service will undertake that tragical execution. In other words, the assassination. So Mary, you know, 17 days to write her reply, she has been mulling over what she should say, mulling it over.
玛丽脱离囚禁。它将与来自法国的入侵相协调。至于伊丽莎白的命运，玛丽没有明确说明会是什么，但她的意思很清楚，因为17天前，这位年轻的天主教绅士安东尼·巴宾顿曾写信给玛丽，并在信中提议暗杀那个他描述为篡位者的女人。换句话说，就是伊丽莎白。所以他写道，有六位高贵的绅士，都是我的私人朋友，他们出于对天主教事业和女王陛下的忠诚，将承担那场悲剧性的处决。换句话说，就是暗杀。所以玛丽，你知道，用了17天来写她的回复，她一直在反复思考她应该说什么，反复思考。
and over in her mind, but now at last she has made up her mind. And that's the significance of that otherwise kind of enigmatic phrase, then shall it be time to set the six gentlemen to work? In other words, get the assassination squad out there. Let them kill Elizabeth. So this is the sixth episode that we've done in this series on the sort of the golden age of Elizabeth I, the rivalry with Spain, the kind of the war in the the shadows, but also the war at sea with Sir Francis Drake and all of this. A Mary Queen of
在她的脑海里，但现在她终于下定了决心。这就是那句原本有些晦涩难懂的话的意义所在：那么就是让那六位绅士开始行动的时候了？换句话说，让暗杀小组出动吧。让他们杀了伊丽莎白。所以这是我们在这个关于伊丽莎白一世黄金时代、与西班牙的竞争、某种阴影中的战争，以及与弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士的海上战争等系列中制作的第六集。苏格兰女王玛丽
Scots has been this presence throughout the whole series. She's been in captivity, but she hasn't really been centre stage. Now, we did a previous series about Mary Queen of Scots, which listeners could look up. We did that in 2025 if they're interested. Let's pull back the camera and talk about exactly who she is. She is Elizabeth's cousin. She is her obvious air, if anything happens to Elizabeth, but the issue is that she's not mainly French and Scottish, but she's a Catholic, and that is the main problem as far as Elizabeth sees it. Yeah, and this has obvious consequences for the kind of the general climate of suspicion and paranoia that has prevailed throughout this series, because Catholics in England, in Scotland and on the continent, all dream of seeing Mary
在整个系列中一直是一个存在。她一直被囚禁，但并没有真正处于中心舞台。我们之前做过一个关于苏格兰女王玛丽的系列节目，听众可以去查阅。如果他们感兴趣的话，我们是在2025年做的。让我们把镜头拉远，谈谈她到底是谁。她是伊丽莎白的表妹。如果伊丽莎白发生什么事，她是显而易见的继承人，但问题是她不仅主要是法国人和苏格兰人，而且她还是个天主教徒，在伊丽莎白看来，这是主要问题。是的，这对整个系列中普遍存在的怀疑和偏执氛围产生了明显的影响，因为英格兰、苏格兰和欧洲大陆的天主教徒都梦想着看到玛丽
on the throne of England. And Protestants, by contrast, see Mary as the great enemy of everything that they hold dear. So if you're an English Protestant, the enemy of Queen Elizabeth, of England and of the Protestant religion. And two of Elizabeth's counsellors in particular, who have featured throughout this series, are absolutely set on bringing her to execution. to seeing Mary Queen of Scott's head chopped off as a traitor to Elizabeth. And these two counsellors are William Cecil Lord Burley, who is Elizabeth's chief minister, and Sir Francis Walsingham, who is her head of intelligence, her spy chief.
登上英格兰的王位。相比之下，新教徒则将玛丽视为他们所珍视的一切的大敌。所以如果你是一个英国新教徒，你就是伊丽莎白女王、英格兰和新教信仰的敌人。伊丽莎白的两位顾问，也就是在整个系列中都有出场的两位，特别坚决地要将她处决。要看到苏格兰女王玛丽作为伊丽莎白的叛徒被砍头。这两位顾问是伊丽莎白的首席大臣威廉·塞西尔（伯利勋爵）和她的情报主管、间谍头子弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆爵士。
And for two decades, effectively, they have seen Mary as this kind of malignant spider, sat at the heart of a great web of international conspiracy. And by 1586, as the storm clouds of war gather over the channel, Mary is coming to see more of a menace even than she had done before. And we've been tracing the reasons for this in our previous episodes. Though three years earlier, listeners may remember in 1583, there had been another plot to overthrow Elizabeth, to place Elizabeth on the throne, to launch a foreign invasion. And this was the Throckmorton plot named after the guy who gets captured and is the first. for guy for it. And that had been exposed and foiled by Walsingham's counter espionage service. And it's this sense of a domestic conspiracy combining with foreign backing that gives
二十年来，他们实际上一直把玛丽视为某种恶毒的蜘蛛，盘踞在巨大国际阴谋网的中心。到了1586年，随着战争的乌云在海峡上空聚集，玛丽在他们眼中变得比以前更加危险。我们在之前的剧集中一直在追踪其中的原因。虽然三年前，听众可能还记得在1583年，曾有另一个推翻伊丽莎白、让伊丽莎白登上王位、发动外国入侵的阴谋。这就是以被捕并首当其冲的家伙命名的特罗克莫顿阴谋。那次阴谋被沃尔辛厄姆的反间谍机构揭露并挫败了。正是这种国内阴谋与外国支持相结合的感觉，让
Walsingham and everyone on Elizabeth's Privy Council, the kind of the hebi-gibis. And now in 1586, that threat of foreign intervention seems to them even greater than ever, because England by now is at war with Spain in all but name. So English and Spanish forces, are openly fighting in the low countries. In our previous episode, we described how Sir Philip Sidney went to war with the Spanish forces in the northern low countries.
沃尔辛厄姆和伊丽莎白枢密院的所有人感到不安。而现在在1586年，外国干预的威胁在他们看来比以往任何时候都大，因为英国现在实际上已经与西班牙处于战争状态。所以英国和西班牙军队在低地国家公开交战。在上一集中，我们描述了菲利普·西德尼爵士是如何在北部低地国家与西班牙军队作战的。
Privatiers are raiding Spain's holdings in the new world, led by the greatest privateer of them all, Sir Francis Drake. And there are reports that in Spain, as a response to these insults, Drake's raids and the English intervention in the low countries, the king of Spain,
私掠船正在袭击西班牙在新世界的领地，由他们中最伟大的私掠船长弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士领导。有报道称，在西班牙，作为对这些侮辱、德雷克的袭击和英国对低地国家干预的回应，西班牙国王，
Philip the second is mustering a great fleet to attack England in Spanish and armada. So it's no surprise that Lord Burgling, or Sassalus he used to be, and Sir Francis Walsingham, are very keen to basically get Mary out of the picture, to eliminate her from this story. They've been wrestling with this issue for a long time, haven't they, since 1572, which was the first time that Mary was pretty clearly implicated in a plot against her cousin, Elizabeth. But the big problem is that Elizabeth does not want to put Mary to death. I mean, partly because she knows it will inflame opinion across Europe, but also there is a sort of personal issue, isn't there, that Elizabeth doesn't want to set a precedent of killing a queen. Yes. So there are all
菲利普二世正在集结一支庞大的舰队来攻击英国，即西班牙无敌舰队。所以难怪伯利勋爵（或者他过去常被称为塞西尔）和弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆爵士非常热衷于基本上让玛丽出局，将她从这个故事中剔除。他们已经为此纠结了很长时间，不是吗？自1572年以来，那是玛丽第一次被相当明确地牵连到针对她表妹伊丽莎白的阴谋中。但最大的问题是伊丽莎白不想处死玛丽。我的意思是，部分原因是她知道这会激怒整个欧洲的舆论，但还有一个个人问题，不是吗？伊丽莎白不想开创处决女王的先例。是的。所以有各种各样的
kinds of reasons why she doesn't want Mary publicly put to death, because she knows that it will cause outrage across Europe and it will provide Philip with a kind of clinching justification for sending that armada against England. And as we've been saying throughout this series, Elizabeth hates war and she hates kind of any sense that she's locked into foreign policy courses. So to quote Garrett Mattingly, this wonderful book on the Spanish Armada that he wrote back in the 1940s, but it's still great. He said of Elizabeth, her foreign policy was to have no foreign policy not alterable.
原因导致她不想公开处死玛丽，因为她知道这会在整个欧洲引起公愤，并为菲利普派遣那支无敌舰队对抗英国提供某种决定性的理由。正如我们在整个系列中所说的那样，伊丽莎白讨厌战争，她讨厌任何感觉自己被锁定在外交政策路线上的感觉。所以引用加勒特·马丁利的话，他在20世纪40年代写的这本关于西班牙无敌舰队的精彩著作，至今仍然很棒。他这样评价伊丽莎白：她的外交政策就是没有外交政策，不会被
by the lightest touch on the helm. And obviously, if Elizabeth is locked into war with Spain, then, you know, that's, that's no longer a course that she can follow. But as you implied, Elizabeth's opposition to having Mary executed goes beyond mere foreign policy concerns. She sees it as a threat to her own authority because Mary, like Elizabeth, is an anointed queen. And Elizabeth doesn't want to license anything that might impair the sense her subjects have of the divinity that hedges a king, as Shakespeare will put it. And obviously, if you're anxious to maintain the sense of dignity that surrounds an anointed monarch, then chopping off her head is not the way to maintain it.
舵上最轻微的触碰所改变。显然，如果伊丽莎白被锁定在与西班牙的战争中，那么，你知道，那就不再是她能遵循的路线了。但正如你所暗示的那样，伊丽莎白反对处决玛丽的原因超出了单纯的外交政策考虑。她将其视为对自己权威的威胁，因为玛丽和伊丽莎白一样，是一位受膏的女王。伊丽莎白不想许可任何可能损害她的臣民对莎士比亚所说的“护卫国王的神性”的感知的事情。显然，如果你急于维持围绕受膏君主的尊严感，那么砍掉她的头并不是维持它的方式。
And for Burley and Walsingham, as you said, this is a complete nightmare. Can I just ask a quick question? You've said a couple of times, she doesn't want to have her publicly executed. Is this not a flaw in Elizabeth I, the First Armory? Why does she not consider killing her privately? I mean, why not, you know, have poison her? She does consider it, and we will be coming to that later in this episode. Yeah, I mean, I'd have killed her already, frankly.
对于伯利和沃尔辛厄姆来说，正如你所说，这简直是一场噩梦。我能问一个简短的问题吗？你已经说了好几次，她不想让她被公开处决。这难道不是伊丽莎白一世的一个缺陷吗？为什么她不考虑私下杀了她？我的意思是，为什么不，你知道，毒死她？她确实考虑过，我们稍后会在这一集中谈到这一点。是的，我的意思是，坦率地说，我早就杀了她了。
I don't understand why she's been dithering. I absolutely know that you would, and it's just a shame that you weren't at the beck and call of the Virgin Queen, as we will see in due course. But for now, I mean, conversely, for Burley and Walsingham, having her publicly executed ticks all kinds of boxes. You know, it very publicly removes her. It brands her as a traitor. it locks them into the war with Spain that they probably feel is coming and it serves to establish a kind of solidarity among the Protestants of England and beyond. So they want that. They also want Mary gone because throughout this period, Elizabeth has no children, she has no husband, she's going to die a virgin.
我不明白她为什么一直在犹豫不决。我绝对知道你会这么做，只是可惜你当时不在“童贞女王”的差遣之下，正如我们稍后将会看到的那样。但就目前而言，我的意思是，相反，对于伯利和沃尔辛厄姆来说，让她被公开处决在各方面都符合要求。你知道，这非常公开地除掉了她。它给她打上了叛徒的烙印。它将他们锁定在他们可能感觉到即将到来的与西班牙的战争中，并且它有助于在英国及其他地区的新教徒之间建立某种团结。所以他们想要那个。他们也想让玛丽消失，因为在这一时期，伊丽莎白没有孩子，没有丈夫，她将作为一个处女死去。
And so if she dies now, then civil war will be the best that they can hope for. The worst is the complete triumph of popery over everything that they have lived for throughout their careers. And of course, it will also result in their own personal ruin. So Burley, who is a very consummate political operator, understands the functioning of the state, understands how Parliament perhaps can interact with Elizabeth's royal power. He's been trying to box Elizabeth in by getting Parliament to pass a very momentous piece of legislation. So this had gone through Parliament in March 1585, and it was called an Act for the Queen's Safety. And by its terms, any claimant to the throne of England who is implicated in a rebellion or an invasion or an assassination plot against Elizabeth is to be put on trial for treason and if convicted of treason to be killed.
所以如果她现在死了，那么内战将是他们所能希望的最好结果。最坏的结果是教皇权在他们职业生涯中为之奋斗的一切之上取得彻底胜利。当然，这也将导致他们个人的毁灭。所以伯利，作为一个非常圆滑的政治操盘手，了解国家的运作，了解议会也许如何能与伊丽莎白的王权互动。他一直试图通过让议会通过一项非常重大的立法来限制伊丽莎白。这项法案于1585年3月在议会通过，被称为《女王安全法》。根据其条款，任何参与针对伊丽莎白的叛乱、入侵或暗杀阴谋的英格兰王位觊觎者都将被以叛国罪审判，如果叛国罪名成立，将被处死。
No one is named in the act, but Mary doesn't need to be named. It's obvious that she is the target. And with this piece of legislation on the statute book, the pressure now is on Walsingham as the head of. of intelligence to find sufficient evidence against Mary, evidence that is watertight enough to satisfy a court of law, that she is indeed guilty of treason. Because if he can do that, the legislation is now at last in place to have her tried and then executed. Okay, so let's turn now to, away from Wilson and Burley to Mary herself. So, You know, when people think about Mary Queen of Scots, they think about Sersia Ronan playing her in the film, right?
法案中没有点名任何人，但玛丽不需要被点名。很明显她是目标。随着这项立法被列入法典，现在的压力在于沃尔辛厄姆作为情报主管，要找到足够的针对玛丽的证据，足以满足法庭要求的、确凿的证据，证明她确实犯有叛国罪。因为如果他能做到这一点，立法现在终于到位，可以审判并处决她了。好吧，那么让我们现在转向，离开沃尔辛厄姆和伯利，转向玛丽本人。所以，你知道，当人们想到苏格兰女王玛丽时，他们会想到西尔莎·罗南在电影中扮演她，对吧？
They think about this elfin, helpless, victim, very beautiful, pale, all of this. In reality, her vibe is very different now. I mean, it's very uncallant for us to say so, Tom, and maybe some, this just may say, we're not in a position to say this, but we'll say it anyway because that's kind of people we are. Certainly I am. She's slightly let herself go. Is that fair? Well, yes, so she is 43 in July 1586 when she's writing that letter, or at least getting her secretary to write that letter.
他们想到这个精灵般的、无助的、受害者形象，非常美丽、苍白，所有这些。实际上，她现在的状态非常不同。我的意思是，汤姆，我们这样说很不礼貌，也许有些人会说，我们没有立场这样说，但我们还是会说，因为我们就是这样的人。当然我是。她稍微有点放任自己了。这公平吗？嗯，是的，所以她在1586年7月写那封信时是43岁，或者至少是让她的秘书写那封信。
But she looks a lot older. So as you said, she's very beautiful as a young woman, famously so. But by now she is overweight and she's very stoop-shouldered. And she also has very serious health issues. So Burley is receiving updates on the state of her health. And he's being told that Mary's legs are swollen and indeed, to quote, are wrapped in grope, matter, which is not very nice. I mean, I don't want to, you know, give myself away,
但她看起来老多了。所以正如你所说，她年轻时非常美丽，闻名遐迩。但现在她超重了，而且背部非常驼。她还有非常严重的健康问题。所以伯利一直在收到关于她健康状况的更新。有人告诉他，玛丽的腿肿了，而且引用原话，被“粗糙的物质”包裹着，这不太好。我的意思是，我不想，你知道，暴露我自己，
but I don't think anyone likes gross matter wrapped around a woman's legs, do they? No, and also people don't like constipation, which Mary is also suffering from. So here's another report. Off times, by reason of great pains through windy matter ascending under her head and other parts, she is ready to swoon. I'm going to cancel that date with Mary Queen of Scots. But, you know, it's not these ailments, the weight gain, the stoop shoulders, and they're not her fault.
但我认为没有人喜欢包裹在女人腿上的粗糙物质，对吧？不，而且人们也不喜欢便秘，玛丽也深受其苦。所以这是另一份报告。由于风性物质上升到她的头部和其他部位引起的剧烈疼痛，她经常准备晕倒。我要取消与苏格兰女王玛丽的约会了。但是，你知道，这些疾病、体重增加、驼背，并不是她的错。
and she has them for kind of two apparently contradictory reasons, both which relate to the ambivalences of her situation in England. So the first is she is a captive. She is under a form of house arrest. And so she can no longer, as she had done when she was a queen, kind of exercise every day. As a queen, you said, Sertia Rohn and Sertia Rohn and galloping around on a horse firing pistols.
她患上这些疾病有两个看似矛盾的原因，这两个原因都与她在英国处境的矛盾有关。第一个是她是一个俘虏。她处于某种软禁状态。所以她不能再像她做女王时那样，每天锻炼了。正如你所说，作为女王，西尔莎·罗南骑着马飞奔，开着手枪。
That was what Mary did as a queen. She was very active woman. But now she's not. She's allowed to go riding at most once or twice a month. And even when she rides in a coach, she's escorted by a squad of musketeers because Walsingham is petrified that a rescue attempt may be made. But at the same time, as she's not getting any exercise, she is being treated with the honour that is due to a queen. Elizabeth insists on that. And in practical terms, that means that wherever she is, there is a groaning table laden down with foods that have been cooked in her own kitchen and served to her by her own staff.
那是玛丽做女王时所做的事。她是一个非常活跃的女人。但现在她不是了。她最多一个月被允许骑马一两次。即使她坐马车，也有一个火枪手小队护送，因为沃尔辛厄姆害怕有人会尝试营救。但与此同时，在她没有得到任何锻炼的情况下，她正受到女王应有的礼遇。伊丽莎白坚持这一点。在实际操作中，这意味着无论她在哪里，都有一张摆满她自己厨房烹饪的食物的桌子，并由她自己的员工服务。
staff, and she demands the full royal protocol. And to quote John Guy from his wonderful biography of Mary, like Elizabeth, Mary enjoyed two courses at both dinner and supper, and each course included 16 separate dishes individually presented and accompanied by bread, wine, salads, and fruit. This meant 32 dishes for each meal and 64 for each day. So that is a lot of food if you're not having any exercise. So 1586, however, so this is in the wake of the Throckmorton plot. Her conditions are a little bit harsher than the high living of previous years, right? So how many meals a day is she down to now?
员工，她要求全套皇家礼仪。引用约翰·盖伊在她精彩的玛丽传记中的话，像伊丽莎白一样，玛丽在午餐和晚餐时都享受两道菜，每道菜包括16道单独呈现的菜肴，并配有面包、葡萄酒、沙拉和水果。这意味着每顿饭有32道菜，每天有64道菜。所以如果你没有任何锻炼，那确实是很多食物。然而1586年，这是在特罗克莫顿阴谋之后。她的条件比前几年的高生活水平要严酷一些，对吧？那么她现在每天吃几顿饭？
Surely no longer 64 a day. It's Amiga 20. 20 and she has to rub by with 48 servants, which is massively slumming it. She's been moved into the kind of timbered mansion that had it survived into the present day it hasn't, would probably be a boutique hotel. This is a place in Staffordshire called Chartley Manor. And it's a very pleasant place to be, but it is surrounded by two moats. So again, she is, you know, she knows that she's effectively in a prison.
肯定不再是每天64道了。是可怜的20道。而且她不得不靠48名仆人过活，这在当时已经是大幅缩减了。她被搬进了一种木结构的豪宅，如果它能保存到今天（它没有），那可能会是一家精品酒店。这是一个位于斯塔福德郡的地方，叫查特利庄园。这是一个非常舒适的地方，但它被两条护城河包围着。所以同样，她知道她实际上是在监狱里。
And she has to suffer all kinds of indignity. So her request for Turkish carpets is turned down. She's not allowed to have fish from the sea. You know, it will have to be caught in the river. And every time she has her canopy decorated with her royal regatta. Galia put up, the guy who is acting as her jailer comes in and tears it down. And the name of this jailer is Sir Amius Powlett. And he is a very kind of hard-nosed, granite-faced Puritan. And he's been given the job of serving as Mary's jailer, because unlike everyone else who has been
她不得不忍受各种侮辱。所以她对土耳其地毯的要求被拒绝了。她不允许吃海里的鱼。你知道，它必须是在河里捕获的。每当她把装饰有她皇家徽章的华盖挂起来时，那个担任她狱卒的人就会进来把它撕掉。这个狱卒的名字叫阿米亚斯·波莱特爵士。他是一个非常强硬、铁石心肠的清教徒。他被委以担任玛丽狱卒的工作，因为与所有其他人不同，那些被
appointed to that job, Powlett can be absolutely relied upon not to succumb to Mary's charm, which remains considerable. Paulette loathes Mary as a kind of as Jezebel, as a papist, and as a Scot with no pity at all of English purses. I think a tremendous phrase. Yeah. He sounds like a great man. But actually she doesn't like him at all, does she?
任命为该工作的人，波莱特绝对可以被信赖，不会屈服于玛丽的魅力，尽管她的魅力依然很大。波莱特厌恶玛丽，认为她是耶洗别，是天主教徒，是一个对英国钱包毫无怜悯之心的苏格兰人。我认为这是一个了不起的短语。是的。他听起来是个伟大的人。但实际上她一点也不喜欢他，对吧？
What do you call him? One of the most whimsical and austere persons whom I've ever known, and in a word, fitter for a jail of criminals. It's odd to have somebody who's both whimsical and austere. But anyway, there he is. And he, I mean, one of the things that he does is he stops her having contacts to the outside world, doesn't he? I mean, you can understand where they've done this. They don't want her plotting with Jesuits and with bad people of various kinds against England.
你称他为什么？“我所认识的最反复无常和严厉的人之一，总之，更适合做一个罪犯的监狱长。”有一个既反复无常又严厉的人是很奇怪的。但无论如何，他就在那里。而且他，我的意思是，他所做的事情之一就是阻止她与外界联系，不是吗？我的意思是，你可以理解他们为什么要这样做。他们不想让她与耶稣会士和各种坏人勾结，反对英国。
And you can understand why they want to kind of exert a much greater control over her in the wake of all these kind of various plots. And as you say, the harshest restrictions concern her contacts with the outside world. You know, she's not allowed to know what is going on beyond the moats of her, this manor house that is her prison. And so she is completely desperate to reestablish contact with sympathizers, to know what prospects there are for her being released from prison, and perhaps what prospects there are for her to win the throne of England, which she is now starting to, you know, to recognize is the only way she's ever going to escape this form of imprisonment. but, you know, how is she to do this? Because Paulette is a very, very effective jailer. You know, he's not allowing her any letters. He conducts random searches of her quarters to check that, you know, she's not hiding notes there. And should anyone from her personal household kind of go out into the outside world, visit the local villages or whatever, then when they come back, they will be subjected to strip searches. So the situation looks really bad for Mary. But over the course of her very length of her very length. the imprisonment in England, she has learnt the value of patience. And fortunately for her, Mary's partisans are patient as well, and they're determined and they are very, very ingenious. And in April, so four months after Mary had been moved to Charlie Manor, an agent from the
你可以理解为什么他们想在所有这些各种阴谋之后对她施加更大的控制。正如你所说，最严厉的限制涉及她与外界的联系。你知道，她不允许知道在她这个监狱庄园的护城河之外发生了什么。所以她完全渴望重新与同情者建立联系，了解她被释放出狱的前景，也许还有她赢得英格兰王位的前景，她现在开始意识到，这是她逃离这种监禁的唯一途径。但是，你知道，她该怎么做呢？因为波莱特是一个非常、非常有效的狱卒。你知道，他不允许她有任何信件。他会对她的住所进行随机搜查，以检查她没有在那里藏匿便条。如果她个人家庭中的任何人走到外面的世界，访问当地村庄什么的，那么当他们回来时，他们将受到搜身。所以玛丽的情况看起来真的很糟糕。但在她漫长的英国监禁期间，她学会了耐心的价值。幸运的是，玛丽的支持者也很有耐心，他们意志坚定，而且非常、非常聪明。四月，也就是玛丽被转移到查特利庄园四个月后，一名来自
French embassy in London manages to get a letter through to her. And this is a guy called Gilbert Gifford. and he is English. He's from Staffordshire. He's Catholic. And he's actually a kinsman of Francis Throckmorton, who had been implicated in the previous plot to set Mary free. He'd studied at one of the seminary set up by William Allen, who is the kind of the great Catholic leader of the exiles on the continent.
伦敦法国大使馆的特工设法给她送去了一封信。这个家伙叫吉尔伯特·吉福德。他是英国人。他来自斯塔福德郡。他是天主教徒。他实际上是弗朗西斯·特罗克莫顿的亲戚，后者曾参与之前的释放玛丽的阴谋。他在威廉·艾伦建立的神学院之一学习过，威廉·艾伦是大陆流亡者中伟大的天主教领袖。
And he'd been ordained a deacon there. And in Paris, where he'd moved to after his ordination, He'd been recruited by Mary's agents in the city and employed as a courier taking letters from Paris to the French embassy in London. But obviously his real ambition is to get letters from the French embassy to Mary in Chartley Manor. And he has come up with what he thinks is a brilliant wheeze that will enable him to do it. And this is like a kind of children's book on Spycraft. the kind of thing you could imagine, I don't know, Ian Blyton or someone coming up with.
他在那里被任命为执事。在巴黎，他在受戒后搬到了那里，他被玛丽在城里的特工招募，并被雇佣为一名快递员，将信件从巴黎带到伦敦的法国大使馆。但显然他真正的野心是将信件从法国大使馆带给查特利庄园的玛丽。他想出了一个他认为是绝妙的计策，使他能够做到这一点。这就像一本关于间谍活动的儿童读物。你可以想象，我不知道，伊恩·布莱顿或某人想出的那种东西。
So Gifford has gone to the local brewer who supplies Chartley Manor with its beer. And Gifford's plan is to put letters for Mary into a kind of a waterproof receptacle or a beerproof receptacle, perhaps you might say. And then to insert this receptacle through the bunghole of the beer, barrel, and then the beer barrel will be taken by the brewer to Chartley Manor. And when it arrives there, the message can be retrieved through the bunghole by Mary's butler, who can then take the correspondence to Mary's secretaries, and they can then pass it on to Mary herself.
所以吉福德去找了当地为查特利庄园供应啤酒的酿酒商。吉福德的计划是将给玛丽的信件放入某种防水容器，或者你可能说是防啤酒容器中。然后将这个容器插入啤酒桶的塞孔中，然后啤酒桶将被酿酒商带到查特利庄园。当它到达那里时，玛丽的管家可以通过塞孔取回信息，然后他可以将信件交给玛丽的秘书，他们随后可以将信件转交给玛丽本人。
And then should Mary want to reply to anything, the whole procedure can operate in reverse. And it sounds mad. I think it sounds good. I think it's a great scheme. Amazingly, well, it works, Dominic. And this is how Babington, with his kind of plot for assassinating Elizabeth with those, you know, those six gentlemen and springing Mary from Charlie Manor, this is how he had been able to get his letter through to her. And it's also why Mary spends so much time kind of mulling over what she's going to, how she's going to reply, because she knows that this is really the one realistic chance she has to escape from her prison. and perhaps to become the Queen of England.
如果玛丽想回复任何事情，整个程序可以反向操作。这听起来很疯狂。我觉得听起来不错。我觉得这是一个很棒的计划。令人惊讶的是，嗯，它奏效了，多米尼克。这就是巴宾顿带着他那种用那六位绅士暗杀伊丽莎白并把玛丽从查特利庄园救出来的阴谋，这就是他能够把信送给她的方式。这也是为什么玛丽花那么多时间反复思考她要回复什么，因为她知道这确实是她逃离监狱的唯一现实机会。
Now, her secretaries say, don't reply. It's too dangerous. There are spies everywhere. And Mary is clearly anxious herself. And so as she is mulling over what she should reply, she's keen to get out into the open to escape the claustrophobia of her quarters. She can't go riding, but she can go out in her carriage. And so this is what she does.
也许还能成为英格兰女王。现在，她的秘书说，不要回复。太危险了。到处都是间谍。玛丽自己显然也很焦虑。所以当她反复思考她应该回复什么时，她渴望走到外面，逃离她住所的幽闭恐惧症。她不能骑马，但她可以坐马车出去。所以这就是她所做的。
She goes for rides around the area. and as she does so, three days before she ends up composing her letter, she looks out of the window and she sees a youngish man and she describes him later as being of low stature, slender every way, dark yellow-haired on the head and clear yellow bearded. And she smiles at him and then the coach rumbles on. And four days later, after she's seen him, so she's had her secretaries write the letter and then the following day,
她在该地区兜风，就在她写信的三天前，她向窗外看去，看到了一个年轻男子，她后来描述他为“身材矮小，各方面都很苗条，头上有深黄色的头发，胡子是浅黄色的”。她对他笑了笑，然后马车继续前行。四天后，在她见到他之后，她让她的秘书写了这封信，第二天，
this letter with its allusion to the six gentlemen who are plotting to kill Elizabeth is placed in the beer barrel in the watertight receptacle. And the barrel is taken away. The brewer is taking it. And Mary is hoping that the brewer will be taking this barrel with its secret message inside to Babbington. And Babington can then take the letter to the French embassy and beyond that to Paris and the wheels of conspiracy can be set in motion. Unfortunately, however, Babington is not the first recipient of Mary's letter.
这封信连同对那六位密谋杀害伊丽莎白的绅士的暗示，被放入了啤酒桶里的防水容器中。桶被带走了。酿酒商正在带走它。玛丽希望酿酒商能把这个装有秘密信息的桶带给巴宾顿。巴宾顿随后可以将信件带到法国大使馆，并进一步带到巴黎，阴谋的齿轮就可以开始转动了。然而不幸的是，巴宾顿并不是玛丽信件的第一个接收者。
Instead, the letter is delivered to the youngest man with yellow hair that she had seen through her coach window. And this is the man who is about to deliver her up to the people who in the long run will have her killed. And the name of this young man with his yellow hair is Thomas Phillips. And he is a linguist. He's a mathematician. and he is the single most gifted cryptanalyst in the employ of Elizabeth's spy chief, Sir Francis Walsingham. So what do we know about this guy, this yellow-haired man? He's Stephen Alford in his great book, The Watchers, says he's secretive, a man who had travelled to the uttermost in the cipher.
相反，这封信被送到了她通过马车窗看到的那个黄头发的年轻人手中。这个人即将把她交给那些最终会杀死她的人。这个黄头发年轻人的名字叫托马斯·菲利普斯。他是一位语言学家。他是一位数学家。他是伊丽莎白间谍头子弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆爵士雇佣的最有天赋的密码分析员。那么我们对这个家伙，这个黄头发的男人了解多少？斯蒂芬·阿尔福德在他伟大的著作《守望者》中说他很神秘，一个“在密码学方面走到了极致”的人。
Do we know anything more about him or is he just a sort of shadowy presence? Well, Stephen Alford says that Phillips is the most kind of secretive, the most mysterious of all the spies in Walsingham's employ and also the ablest. So in addition to being the greatest code breaker, the greatest cipher breaker in Walsingham's employ, he is also the best handler of double agents. And this is why Walsingham has sent Phillips to Stafford to supervise this entire very complex operation. Because Gilbert Gifford, so that's the young seminarian who'd been recruited by Mary's agents
我们对他还有更多了解吗，还是他只是某种阴影般的存在？嗯，斯蒂芬·阿尔福德说，菲利普斯是沃尔辛厄姆雇佣的所有间谍中最神秘、最隐秘的，也是最有能力的。所以除了是沃尔辛厄姆雇佣的最伟大的密码破译者、最伟大的密码破译者之外，他也是双重间谍的最佳操纵者。这就是为什么沃尔辛厄姆派菲利普斯去斯塔福德监督整个非常复杂的操作。因为吉尔伯特·吉福德，也就是那个被玛丽的特工在巴黎招募来担任快递员的年轻神学院学生，
in Paris to serve as a courier, he too has been recruited. recruited by Walsingham. Walsingham has turned him. And Gifford's approach to Mary had been a set-up supervised by Phillips. And it's Phillips as well who had recruited the brewer. I said, basically, you know, he's holding all the strings. And he has been opening all the correspondence between Babington and Mary. He's been decrypting what Babington may have written or what Mary may have written, reading it through and then he is another of his many talents is that he's able to reseal letters that he's opened and make it look as though they have never been opened. And so because of this, he can then forward these letters that he's read to the intended recipients
他也已经被招募了。被沃尔辛厄姆招募。沃尔辛厄姆已经策反了他。吉福德接近玛丽的过程是由菲利普斯监督的圈套。也是菲利普斯招募了酿酒商。我说，基本上，你知道，他掌握着所有的线索。他一直在打开巴宾顿和玛丽之间的所有信件。他一直在解密巴宾顿可能写的内容或玛丽可能写的内容，读完之后，他还有许多才能中的另一个，就是他能够重新密封他打开的信件，并使它们看起来好像从未被打开过一样。因此，由于这一点，他随后可以将他读过的这些信件转发给预期的收件人，
and they have no idea that the contents have already been read by Walsingham's spy agency. These people are brilliant, Tom, and she has walked right into it. I admire them for this. I mean, she has, but, you know, she has no choice, I think, as she sees it. she's aware that there's a risk. She's very smart. I mean, she knows what she's up against, but I think she's desperate. As you say, she has walked into it because Phillips has had read Babington's letter to Mary with its mention of the six noble gentlemen ready to kill Elizabeth. And so he has been waiting on tenterhooks to find out how Mary's going to reply, because he
他们根本不知道内容已经被沃尔辛厄姆的间谍机构读过了。这些人太聪明了，汤姆，而她直接走进了圈套。我很佩服他们这一点。我的意思是，她确实走进了圈套，但是，你知道，我认为她别无选择。她意识到有风险。她很聪明。我的意思是，她知道她面对的是什么，但我认为她很绝望。正如你所说，她走进了圈套，因为菲利普斯读过巴宾顿写给玛丽的信，其中提到了准备杀死伊丽莎白的六位高贵绅士。所以他一直如坐针毡地等待着玛丽会如何回复，因为他
knows that if she replies favorably, if she says, oh yeah, let's get the six gentlemen operating, then that's it. They've got her. And so he, you know, he gets this letter that's been sent back by Mary supposedly to Babington, but in fact it's been brought to Phillips. He opens the letter. I'm probably not with trembling hands because he seems to be a very cool customer, but definitely. I mean, his heart must have been pounding. And he reads it through and he is not disappointed by what he finds. He decipheres Mary's letter. There is the reference to the six gentlemen. He writes it up, makes a copy in English, which he then sends to Walsingham. And on the copy of the letter that he sends to Walsingham, he inscribes it with a drawing of a gallows, but he might as well
知道如果她回复得好，如果她说，哦，是的，让那六位绅士行动起来，那么就是这样。他们抓住她了。所以他，你知道，他收到了这封玛丽据说是寄回给巴宾顿的信，但实际上它被带到了菲利普斯那里。他打开了信。可能不是用颤抖的手，因为他似乎是一个非常冷静的人，但绝对是。我的意思是，他的心一定在狂跳。他读了一遍，并没有对所发现的内容感到失望。他解密了玛丽的信。那里提到了那六位绅士。他把它写下来，制作了一份英文副本，然后发给了沃尔辛厄姆。在他发给沃尔辛厄姆的信件副本上，他刻上了一个绞刑架的图画，但他本可以画一个砍头台和一把斧头，他称之为“血腥的信”，因为这个菲利普斯觉得这就是那封注定要让苏格兰女王玛丽灭亡的信，她当然不知道发生了什么。而与此同时，玛丽一直希望信件已经送达，并且也许已经启动了一个阴谋来让她从监狱中获得自由。所以三周半后，是8月11日。玛丽当然对此一无所知。她的狱卒，那个反复无常和严厉的波莱特先生，他通常对她很不友好，对她说，你想去猎鹿吗？她没有想，哦，这有点可疑。
have drawn a chopping block and an axe, and he describes it as the bloody letter, because this Phillips feels is the letter that is going to doom Mary Queen of Scots, who of course has no idea what has happened. And all the while, Mary is hoping that the letter has got through and that Perhaps a plot has been set in motion to set her free from her prison. So three and a half weeks later, it's the 11th of August. Mary, of course, knows nothing of this. And her jailer, the whimsical and austere, Mr. Paulett, who's usually very unfriendly to her, says to her, would you like to go on a deer hunt, doesn't he? And she doesn't think, oh, this is a bit suspicious.
她想，哦，猎鹿，太棒了。特别是她的腿，那个粗糙物质的问题似乎已经清除了。是的，渗出已经停止了。到了一定程度。所以她骑上一匹马，这将证明是她将要进行的最后一次骑马。
She thinks, oh, deer hunt, brilliant. Especially as her legs, the issue of the gross matter seems to have cleared up. Yeah, the oozing has ceased. to a degree. So she gets on a horse for what is going to prove the last horse ride that she will ever take.
她和波莱特一起飞奔进庄园周围的树林里。他们没走多远就看到一队骑兵走近。玛丽的心，当然，我的意思是，它跳动起来。你知道，她在想，这些人是巴宾顿派来的吗？
And she gallops out with Paulette into the woods that surround the manor. And they haven't gone far when they see a troop of horsemen approaching. And Mary's heart, of course, I mean, it leaps. You know, she's thinking, are these the men who've been sent by Babington
来让我获得自由？他的阴谋实现了吗？也许伊丽莎白死了。也许他们来带我去伦敦，让我登上英格兰的王位。果然，骑兵队长骑马来到她身边，他不太礼貌地对她说话。他告诉玛丽，一个针对伊丽莎白生命的阴谋已经被揭露，然后他通知玛丽，她被
to set me free? Has his plot come to fruition? Perhaps Elizabeth is dead. Perhaps they're coming to take me to London and set me on the throne of England. And sure enough, the captain of horse rides up to her, and he addresses her not very politely. And he tells Mary that a plot against the life of Elizabeth has been uncovered, and he then informs Mary that she is under
逮捕了。而此时，玛丽还不知道，巴宾顿阴谋中的一些共谋者已经被逮捕了。巴宾顿本人在三天后的8月14日被捕，他受到了反复审讯，他的审讯者非常清楚，他完全被菲利普斯欺骗了，他甚至吞下了沃尔辛厄姆和菲利普斯共同炮制的一种令人发指的伪造信件，旨在从他那里榨取更直接的供词。最终，巴宾顿和阴谋中的其他共谋者确实承认密谋释放玛丽，赞助外国入侵，
arrest. And by this point, unbeknownst to Mary, a number of the conspirators in Babington's plot have already been apprehended. And Babington himself was arrested three days later on the 14th of August and he was subjected to repeated interrogation and it became very clear to his interrogators that he had been completely hoodwinked by Phillips and that he'd even swallowed a kind of outrageous forgery that Walsingham and Phillips had concocted between them, which was designed to extract an even more direct confession out of him. And in the event, Babington and the other conspirators in the plot did confess to plotting Mary's release, to sponsoring a foreign invasion. and to working for the restoration of Catholicism.
并致力于恢复天主教。我的意思是，他们真的无法不承认。他们被抓了个正着。然而，有趣的是，他们确实否认密谋暗杀伊丽莎白。我认为原因在于他们知道这就是会害死玛丽的事情。如果他们说，是的，玛丽参与了暗杀伊丽莎白的阴谋，那么那就会害死玛丽，他们不想那样做。显然，他们被极其恐怖地处决了。所以巴宾顿本人于9月20日被公开处决。
I mean, they couldn't really not. They'd been, you know, they were banged to rights. They did, however, interestingly, deny plotting to murder Elizabeth. And I think the reason for this was that they knew that that is what would do Mary. If they said, yes, Mary was in on the plot to assassinate Elizabeth, then that would do Mary, and they didn't want to do that. Obviously, they are put horribly to death. So Babington himself was publicly executed on the 20th of September.
我的意思是，他们确实无法抵赖。你知道，他们已经是证据确凿了。然而有趣的是，他们否认密谋刺杀伊丽莎白。我认为原因在于他们知道这会害了玛丽。如果他们承认玛丽参与了刺杀伊丽莎白的阴谋，那就会害了玛丽，而他们不想那样做。显然，他们被处以了极刑。因此，巴宾顿本人于9月20日被公开处决。
His fellow conspirators were executed the fourth. following day, and the site of this was in Hoban. It's where Tottencourt Road tube station is, so it's that kind of great traffic intersection now. And their deaths are very, very horrible. Elizabeth had insisted that they be as salutary as they possibly could. And once their kind of maimed and bleeding corpses lay spread eagled on the scaffold, they had then been chopped up into quarters and distributed to the various gates of the city of London to serve as warnings to the fate of traitors. Meanwhile, what of Mary? Well, she has been ordered to prepare for her departure from Chartley Manor and she leaves on the 21st of September, even as the second batch of plotters who had
她的同谋者们在第四天被处决，地点就在霍本。那里现在是托特纳姆法院路地铁站所在地，所以现在是一个非常繁忙的交通枢纽。他们的死状非常非常凄惨。伊丽莎白坚持要让他们的死起到尽可能大的警示作用。当他们残缺不全、血肉模糊的尸体被大字型摊开在断头台上后，他们又被剁成四块，分送到伦敦城的各个城门，以警告那些企图叛国的人。与此同时，玛丽怎么样了？好吧，她被命令准备离开查特利庄园，并于9月21日启程，尽管此时第二批密谋营救她的阴谋者们正在霍本走向他们可怕的结局。
conspired to free her were meeting their terrible ends in Hoban. And she was accompanied by an absolutely enormous wagon train loaded down with clothes, with furnishings, with assorted luxuries, because even in these dire straits, Mary remains what she has always been a complete diva. And it takes her days to travel the 80 miles from Chartley Manor to the place that Elizabeth had personally chosen as her new place of imprisonment. But finally, on the 25th of September, so they've been on the road for four days, Mary's journey comes to an end. And she has arrived in Fothering Gay Castle. We all know what's coming next. a lot of us doing, even if you don't. It's going to be good. All right. So join us after the
她随行的是一支规模极其庞大的马车队，装满了衣服、家具和各种奢侈品，因为即使在如此困境中，玛丽依然是她一贯的样子——一个彻头彻尾的“天后”。她花了几天时间才走完从查特利庄园到伊丽莎白亲自为她选定的新囚禁地那80英里的路程。但最终，在9月25日，也就是他们在路上走了四天之后，玛丽的旅程结束了。她抵达了福瑟林盖城堡。我们都知道接下来会发生什么。我们很多人都知道，即使你不知道。这会很精彩。好了。那么，休息之后请加入我们，继续收听苏格兰女王玛丽故事的结局。本集由亚马逊赞助播出。现在，自工业革命以来，资本主义社会的一大主题就是改革和改善不公正现象的愿望。我想一个典型的例子就是维多利亚时代推动禁止让年幼的孩子被送进烟囱去做清扫工。
break for the end of the story of Mary Queen of Scots. This episode is brought to you by Amazon. Now, ever since the Industrial Revolution, one of the great themes of capitalist society has been the desire to reform and improve injustices. And I suppose a classic example of this would be the drive in the Victorian period to stop young children being sent up chimneys to work there as sweeps. Yeah, and you can draw a thread, can't you, between the fight for kind of better rights for workers and better working conditions and benefits and things in the 19th century, all the way through to what happens in the 21st. So a good example of the kind of benefits that employees get these days. The benefits that Amazon offers to its employees. So they get funding of up to
是的，你可以从中理出一条线索，不是吗？从19世纪争取更好的工人权利、改善工作条件和福利的斗争，一直延续到21世纪发生的事情。所以，一个很好的例子就是员工如今能获得的福利。亚马逊为其员工提供的福利。他们可以获得每年高达
3,000 pounds a year, every year, towards training and career growth. And Amazon offers term time working to employees with school-aged children. So they can apply to get a guaranteed 10 weeks off in the year to coincide with school holidays, all the while continuing to have access to their full benefits. Find out more at aboutamson.com.uk slash benefits dash and dash. workplace. Want to talk ETS with the people behind them? Join me, Etienne Jean-Cabouchard on the upside ticker talk. We dive into what's moving markets with timely analysis, trends, and answers to ETF questions you've actually been thinking about. Hit play on the upside ticker talk and
3000英镑的培训和职业发展资金。亚马逊还为有学龄儿童的员工提供学期工作制。因此，他们可以申请保证每年有10周的假期，以配合学校假期，同时继续享受全额福利。欲了解更多信息，请访问 aboutamazon.co.uk/benefits-and-workplace。想和ETF背后的专家聊聊吗？请加入我，Etienne Jean-Cabouchard的《Upside Ticker Talk》。我们将通过及时的分析、趋势和对你真正关心的ETF问题的解答，深入探讨市场的动向。点击播放《Upside Ticker Talk》，
elevate your ETF investing IQ. Welcome back to The Rest is History. Mary Queen of Scots has just arrived at Fothering Gay Castle. Now this is the one thing that Fotheringay castle is really known for. And it's a sort of detail that everybody always remembers. Oh, yeah, she, you know, the last chapter of her life is a fathering gay. But actually, I've got no sense of like, like, what fathering gay looks like, or I don't really have that much of a sense of where it is. It's Northamptenshire, isn't it? So it's in a sort of slightly nondescript middle of England. Yeah. Why don't we know what it looks like? Because it doesn't exist anymore. Yeah, the castle has pretty much vanished. I mean, Father and Gay is a great place to visit,
提升你的ETF投资智商。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。苏格兰女王玛丽刚刚抵达福瑟林盖城堡。这是福瑟林盖城堡真正出名的一点。这是一个每个人都会记住的细节。“哦，是的，她生命的最后一章是在福瑟林盖度过的。”但实际上，我对于福瑟林盖长什么样，或者它在哪里，并没有太多的概念。是在北安普敦郡，对吧？所以它位于英格兰中部一个稍微有点平淡无奇的地方。是的。为什么我们不知道它长什么样？因为它已经不存在了。是的，城堡几乎已经消失了。我的意思是，福瑟林盖是一个很棒的旅游景点，
because it has a wonderful church that was a kind of a monument to the Yorkist regime. So if you're interested in the Wars of the Roses and Richard the 3rd is great. But there are very few memorials to the place where Mary, you know, it's her final place of imprisonment. But so just to describe what was there when she arrives in September 1587, as you said, Dominic, it's Northamptonshire, which is the middle of England. So as far away from Scotland and the sea as possible, they've got to make sure that she's not rescued. The ground around the castle is kind of very boggy and treacherous, so that helps as well. The castle itself is on a kind of raised hill. like Chartley Manor, it has a double moat. Unlike Chartley Manor, it has very thick walls, a very imposing
因为它有一座宏伟的教堂，那是约克王朝的一种纪念碑。所以如果你对玫瑰战争和理查三世感兴趣，那很棒。但对于玛丽——你知道，这是她最后的囚禁地——的纪念物却很少。那么，描述一下1587年9月她抵达时那里是什么样子，正如你所说，多米尼克，那是北安普敦郡，也就是英格兰中部。所以尽可能远离苏格兰和大海，他们必须确保她不会被营救。城堡周围的地面非常泥泞且危险，所以这也有帮助。城堡本身坐落在一个隆起的小山上。像查特利庄园一样，它有双重护城河。与查特利庄园不同的是，它有非常厚的墙，一个非常宏伟的
gateway, a colossal kind of Norman keep. So it is effectively as a prison impregnable and there is no real prospect of Mary escaping it. But that's not the only reason that Elizabeth has fixed on Fotheringay as Mary's place of imprisonment. Because Fotherham Gray, as well as fortifications, also has a great sprawling complex of state rooms. And these include, a great hall, so capable of containing large numbers of people. And on the first floor of these staterooms, there is what was called a presence chamber, which is a room where the monarch, if she arrives, the throne can be placed there, and she can keep state, and all the people around can come and pay their respects to her. And it's in this presence chamber on the 14th of
大门，还有一个巨大的诺曼式主塔。所以它实际上是一个坚不可摧的监狱，玛丽几乎没有逃脱的可能。但这并不是伊丽莎白选择福瑟林盖作为玛丽囚禁地的唯一原因。因为福瑟林盖除了防御工事外，还有一个巨大的、错综复杂的国家厅室建筑群。其中包括一个大厅，足以容纳大量的人。在这些厅室的二楼，有一个所谓的“觐见厅”，这是一个房间，如果君主驾临，可以将王座放置在那里，她可以在那里保持威仪，周围的所有人都可以来向她致敬。正是在这个觐见厅，1586年10月14日，
October 1586 that the trial of Mary Queen of Scots opens. And Elizabeth herself is not there. But it feels like she is because her empty throne presides over the whole trial. It's positioned beneath a great cloth of state emblazoned with her royal arms. And so it dominates the proceedings. Mary's judges, they are sitting around a table that's placed in the center of the room. And then around that table, there are three benches. And one of them is facing the kind of the empty. thrown at the opposite end of the room. And the other two are set at right angles to it. So kind of
苏格兰女王玛丽的审判开始了。伊丽莎白本人并没有出席。但感觉她就在那里，因为她那空着的王座主持了整个审判。它被放置在一块绣有她皇家纹章的巨大华盖之下。因此，它主宰了整个诉讼程序。玛丽的法官们坐在房间中央的一张桌子旁。在那张桌子周围，有三条长凳。其中一条正对着房间另一端空着的王座。另外两条则与它成直角放置。所以，
framing the space in which the table had been set. Essentially, there's the throne and then there are kind of benches at right angles to the throne and a bench at the far end of the room. And on these three benches are sat the commissioners who've been appointed by Elizabeth to the trial. So these are the privy councillors and assorted kind of supplementary peers, so barons and vicounts and earls. The leading figures in the state. Walsingham is there, obviously. So too is Sir Christopher Hatton, Elizabeth's great favourite, the sponsor of Drake on his circumnavigation of the globe. But there's no question, who is the guy in ultimate charge of the proceedings. And this is William Cecil, Lord Burley, because this is the moment he has been
框定了放置桌子的空间。本质上，那里有王座，然后有与王座成直角的长凳，以及房间尽头的一条长凳。在这三条长凳上坐着伊丽莎白任命的审判专员。这些人是枢密院议员和各种补充的贵族，比如男爵、子爵和伯爵。国家的主要人物。沃尔辛厄姆显然在那里。克里斯托弗·哈顿爵士也是，他是伊丽莎白最宠爱的人，是德雷克环球航行的赞助人。但毫无疑问，谁是最终负责诉讼程序的人。这就是威廉·塞西尔，伯利勋爵，因为这是他一直在
waiting for. This is the moment that he has been working towards for many decades, long before even Mary Queen of Scots had sought refuge in England. His great aim has been to bring Mary Queen of Scots down right from the very beginning. To bring her to justice, you might say, but of course, does she have a place at this trial at all? Because she's a queen. She's not a subject. And she's not a subject of Elizabeth I, the first. You know, she's not even English. So is this, is it actually legal? I guess that's the question. Well, that's the point she makes. I should, I should betray the dignity and majesty of kings, and it would be tantamount to a confession that I am bound to submit to the laws of England.
等待的时刻。这是他几十年来一直致力于实现的时刻，甚至在苏格兰女王玛丽寻求在英格兰避难之前很久就开始了。他从一开始的伟大目标就是打倒苏格兰女王玛丽。你可以说，是将她绳之以法，但当然，她在这次审判中真的有一席之地吗？因为她是一位女王。她不是臣民。她也不是伊丽莎白一世的臣民。你知道，她甚至不是英国人。所以这是，这真的合法吗？我想这就是问题所在。好吧，这就是她提出的观点。我应该背叛国王的尊严和威严，这等同于承认我有义务服从英格兰的法律。
Well, she's got a Scottish accent now. Well, she had a very pretty Scottish accent, is the report. So she's pretty obdurate. It's a bit like her grandson, Charles I first, when he gets put on trial at the end of the English Civil War. He refuses to recognise the court, and this is basically Mary's strategy. And this is infuriating for Burley. And so he leads a succession of delegations to try and persuade her otherwise.
好吧，她现在有苏格兰口音了。嗯，据报道，她有非常悦耳的苏格兰口音。所以她相当顽固。这有点像她的孙子查理一世，当他在英国内战结束时受审时。他拒绝承认法庭，这基本上就是玛丽的策略。这让伯利感到愤怒。于是他领导了一系列代表团试图说服她改变主意。
But she just seems completely obdurate. And she tells Burley, very memorable terms, look to your consciences and remember that the theatre of the whole world is wider than the kingdom of England. But the guy who ultimately is able to persuade her is the very fluent and plausible Sir Christopher Hatton. And he says to her, if you be innocent, you wrong your reputation in avoiding a trial. And the subtext there, I think, is very clear. He's saying that the trial is going to go ahead whether you are there or not. And if you are not there, then your absence will be interpreted as an admission of guilt. What have you got to fear if you're innocent?
但她似乎完全顽固不化。她以非常令人难忘的措辞告诉伯利：“审视你们的良心，记住整个世界的剧场比英格兰王国更广阔。”但最终能够说服她的人是口才极好且言辞动听的克里斯托弗·哈顿爵士。他对她说：“如果你是无辜的，逃避审判会损害你的名誉。”我认为其中的潜台词非常清楚。他是在说，无论你在不在，审判都会继续进行。如果你不在，那么你的缺席将被解读为认罪。如果你是无辜的，你有什么好怕的？
Yeah. And so Mary feels the force of this and she spends a very restless night wondering what she should do. And finally, on the day that is scheduled for the start of the trial, she says, yes, okay, I will attend. And so she arrives in the courtroom shortly after 9 o'clock in the morning. she's wearing a long black dress of made of velvet, a white cap and a long white veil that covers her hair. And as she enters, everyone stands and takes off their hats. So it's a mark of respect to her as a queen. And she acknowledges these marks with a kind of slighting cline of her head.
是的。所以玛丽感受到了这种压力，她度过了一个非常不安的夜晚，思考着她该怎么做。最终，在预定审判开始的那天，她说：“好吧，我会出席。”于是她在早上9点过后不久抵达了法庭。她穿着一件长款黑色天鹅绒连衣裙，戴着一顶白色的帽子和一条遮住头发的长长白色面纱。当她进入时，所有人都站起来脱下帽子。所以这是对她作为女王的一种尊重。她以微微点头的方式回应了这些敬意。
But having said that, she is completely indignant that her chair is below Elizabeth's throne because it implies that she is subject to Elizabeth. So she has a kind of a bit of a strop about that. She does have three ladies in waiting attending her. These are the only women, obviously, in the courtroom. And these ladies in waiting are the only people who are sympathetic to Mary. Mary does not have a lawyer with her. She doesn't have a kind of barrister who is speaking on her behalf.
但话虽如此，她对自己的椅子低于伊丽莎白的王座感到非常愤慨，因为这意味着她从属于伊丽莎白。所以她为此发了一点脾气。她确实有三位侍女陪同。显然，她们是法庭上仅有的女性。这些侍女是唯一同情玛丽的人。玛丽没有带律师。她没有那种为她辩护的辩护律师。
And instead, she is completely surrounded by enemies and by two in particular. Because just across from where she is sitting, so right in her eyeline next to the Lord Chancellor, is Lord Burley, and at a further remove on the bench reserve for night, so this is the bench that is facing the throne of the empty throne of Elizabeth, is a man that she had only met for the first time that very morning, and this is Sir Francis Walsingham. So she's looking at the two men who have basically done more than anybody else to bring her to this point, and do you think she thinks not that at that point? You know, that she's been told, if you're innocent, you've got nothing to fear, but do you think she thinks at this point when
相反，她完全被敌人包围了，特别是被两个人包围。因为就在她坐的地方对面，也就是在她的视线范围内，紧挨着大法官的是伯利勋爵，而在为骑士保留的长凳上，也就是正对着伊丽莎白空王座的那条长凳上，坐着一个她那天早上才第一次见到的人，这就是弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆爵士。所以她看着这两个基本上比任何人都更努力将她推向这一步的人，你认为她在那一刻想到了吗？你知道，她被告知，“如果你是无辜的，你没什么好怕的”，但你认为当她
she sees them looking at her, when she sees that her chair is lower than Elizabeth's throne, all that stuff, do you think she thinks, okay, this is a done deal? Like, this is a show trial, I'm never going to get off? Or is she thinking I can still turn this around? It's hard to know. I imagine that probably in her heart, she knows that she would not have been brought to trial had the determination of her enemies, not been to see her executed. But against that, she doesn't know what evidence is going to be presented against her. And the whole way, through, she has been insistent that, you know, she's put nothing to paper in her own handwriting. She's been very careful about that.
看到他们盯着她，当她看到她的椅子比伊丽莎白的王座低，所有这些事情，你认为她想，“好吧，这已经成定局了？这就像是一场作秀审判，我永远无法脱身？”还是她在想“我还能扭转局面”？很难知道。我想大概在她的内心深处，她知道如果不是因为敌人的决心就是要处决她，她就不会被送上审判台。但反过来说，她不知道会有什么证据被提交出来反对她。而且一直以来，她都坚持认为，你知道，她没有亲笔写下任何东西。她对此非常小心。
And, you know, she must assume that people haven't seen the letters that she wrote to Babington. She doesn't know about this. No one's told her. So, you know, she probably has a kind of scintilla of hope. But I think the moment that the proceeding start, she must have felt this kind of sickening, cold hand of dread clamping at her heart because Thomas Phillips, you know, the fairhead young man that she'd seen from her coach, he has prepared the evidence against her very diligently and very, very remorselessly and it is all laid out there for the commissioners to study.
而且，你知道，她一定认为人们没有看到她写给巴宾顿的信。她不知道这件事。没有人告诉她。所以，你知道，她可能还有一丝希望。但我认为当诉讼程序开始的那一刻，她一定感到了那种令人作呕的、冰冷的恐惧之手紧紧抓住了她的心脏，因为托马斯·菲利普斯，你知道，那个她从马车里看到的金发年轻人，他非常勤奋且非常无情地准备了反对她的证据，这一切都摆在那里供专员们研究。
So Babington's correspondence with Mary, Mary's correspondence with Babington and her various friends and allies abroad and most fateful of all that letter which Phillips had termed the bloody letter and illustrated with the gallows. I mean, that is the letter that is going to destroy her. And when Mary realizes that all her correspondence had been penetrated by Walsingham, I mean, she is stunned. At that point, surely she knows the game is up. And she, she sobs. You know, she is good at at weeping on demand. And other times when she's not weeping, she goes very spiritedly on the attack,
所以巴宾顿与玛丽的通信，玛丽与巴宾顿以及她在国外的各种朋友和盟友的通信，以及最致命的，那封菲利普斯称之为“血腥信件”并配有绞刑架插图的信。我的意思是，那封信将摧毁她。当玛丽意识到她所有的通信都被沃尔辛厄姆渗透时，我的意思是，她惊呆了。在那一刻，她肯定知道大势已去了。而且她，她啜泣着。你知道，她很擅长按需哭泣。而在其他不哭的时候，她会非常有精神地发起攻击，
and she plays all her favorite cards. She says, you know, I'm not answerable for what people like Babington wrote to me. I had no influence on him whatsoever. She says that the letters attributed to her were not in her own handwriting. And she declares, can I be responsible for the criminal projects
她打出了她所有的王牌。她说，你知道，我不对像巴宾顿这样的人写给我的东西负责。我对他没有任何影响。她说归于她的信件不是她亲笔写的。她宣称，我能对几个绝望之人的犯罪计划负责吗？
of a few desperate men, which they planned without my knowledge, or participation. And she also makes sure to respond directly to the two men that she now appreciates are her two greatest foes. So on the opening day of the trial, she accuses Walsingham, I mean correctly, of having tampered with her letters. That's exactly what Walsingham and Phillips had done. And his response is a magnificent display of ambivalence. He says, I call God and all the world to witness that as a private person, I have done nothing on worthy of an honest man and as Secretary of State, nothing unbefitting my duty. And as Stephen
他们是在我不知情或未参与的情况下策划的。她还确保直接回应那两个她现在意识到是她最大敌人的男人。所以在审判的第一天，她指责沃尔辛厄姆——我的意思是，正确地指责——篡改了她的信件。这正是沃尔辛厄姆和菲利普斯所做的。而他的回应是一场精彩的矛盾展示。他说：“我呼吁上帝和全世界作证，作为一个私人，我没有做任何有损于诚实人的事；作为国务大臣，我没有做任何不符合我职责的事。”正如斯蒂芬·
Orford puts it, this is a masterpiece of subtle wordplay that said everything and nothing at the same time. Walsingham is such a terrifying man to have your enemy, I think. What about Burley? He's also a great man. And she confronts him directly, doesn't she? People may remember who listen to our first series of Mary Queen of Scots that when she arrived in England, she wrote to Berley and said, I hope that you will be my, you know, you will speak to me to the queen on my behalf. And it's evident from that letter that she had no idea how much Burley hated her and how hard he'd been working to destroy her. And it's as though now at her trial that she suddenly realized what Burley has been up to all these long years. And she kind of says to him, you are indeed my enemy, as though this is a blinding realization.
奥福德所说，这是一部微妙的文字游戏杰作，同时说了一切又什么都没说。我认为沃尔辛厄姆是一个作为敌人非常可怕的人。伯利呢？他也是一个伟大的人。她直接面对他，不是吗？听过我们第一系列《苏格兰女王玛丽》的听众可能记得，当她抵达英格兰时，她写信给伯利说：“我希望你会是我的，你知道，你会代表我向女王说话。”从那封信中可以明显看出，她根本不知道伯利有多恨她，也不知道他为了摧毁她付出了多少努力。而现在在她的审判中，她似乎突然意识到伯利这些年来一直在做什么。她有点对他说：“你确实是我的敌人。”仿佛这是一个令人震惊的发现。
and Burley's reply, yes, I am the enemy of the enemies of Queen Elizabeth. So she's clearly, you know, she by day two, she really must know that she's, you know, she's staring at oblivion. And actually she has a sort of meltdown, doesn't she at the end of day two? She just decides there's no reason for her to stay. I mean, there's nothing she can say or do that is going to change the verdict that is looming. And so she rises to her feet. She declares that she forgives the commissioners for what is clearly a charade, a show trial. And then amazingly, she crosses the room to where Walsingham is sitting and she has private words in his ear.
而伯利的回答是：“是的，我是伊丽莎白女王敌人的敌人。”所以她显然，你知道，到第二天，她真的必须知道她，你知道，她正凝视着遗忘。实际上，她在第二天结束时有点崩溃，不是吗？她只是决定没有理由留下来。我的意思是，她说什么或做什么都无法改变即将到来的判决。于是她站了起来。她宣称她原谅了专员们进行这场显然是闹剧的作秀审判。然后令人惊讶的是，她穿过房间走到沃尔辛厄姆坐的地方，在他耳边说了私房话。
And nobody hears what she says to him. But it is apparent to people watching that Walsingham is very angered by what Mary is telling him. And then once she's finished talking to Walsingham, she turns and addresses the entire commission again. and she insists one last time on her innocence. I place my cause in the hands of God. No speculation about what she said to Walsingham? How can we know? But why would it languor him?
没有人听到她对他说了什么。但观察的人很明显，沃尔辛厄姆对玛丽告诉他的话感到非常愤怒。然后当她说完话后，她转过身再次向整个委员会发表讲话，她最后一次坚持自己的清白。“我把我的事业交到上帝手中。”对于她对沃尔辛厄姆说了什么，没有猜测吗？我们怎么可能知道？但为什么这会让他愤怒？
I mean, he's won. He's always about to win. I imagine she accused him of cheating, of fraudulent behavior, cast aspersions on his honour, I would guess. Okay. So she's placed her cause in the hands of God, and what does God say? What does God decide?
我的意思是，他赢了。他一直都要赢了。我想她指责他作弊、欺诈，诋毁他的名誉，我猜。好吧。所以她把她的事业交到了上帝手中，上帝说了什么？上帝决定了什么？
Well, God doesn't really, it isn't really very helpful because the verdict of guilty is duly brought in, actually not in Fotheringay, but in the Star Chamber in Westminster, and it's delivered 10 days after the end of Mary's trial, and the reason for the delay is the inevitable one that Elizabeth doesn't know what to do. And delay and prevarication is always Elizabeth's answer
好吧，上帝并没有真正，这并没有什么帮助，因为有罪的判决被正式带进来了，实际上不是在福瑟林盖，而是在威斯敏斯特的星室法庭，它是在玛丽审判结束10天后作出的，而延迟的原因是不可避免的，即伊丽莎白不知道该怎么办。而拖延和推诿总是伊丽莎白的回答，
to insoluble puzzles, because she's still in agonies at the thought of Mary, who is an anointed queen suffering execution. And if she suffers execution, then definitely this will bring war down on England. It will definitely mean that Phillips Armada is sent against her kingdom. But also there is the fact that Mary has been convicted under this act that had been brought in the year before, the Act for the Queen's safety.
对于无法解决的难题，因为她仍然在想到玛丽——一位受膏的女王——遭受处决而感到痛苦。如果她遭受处决，那么这肯定会给英格兰带来战争。这肯定意味着菲利普的无敌舰队会被派来对付她的王国。但还有一个事实是，玛丽是根据前一年引入的《女王安全法》被定罪的。
So if Mary is now executed, then Elizabeth's worry is that it will seem that Parliament has licensed it. and that therefore Parliament has the right to commit regicide. And this is something that Elizabeth doesn't want. And, you know, in the long run, Mary's grandson, Charles I, is also going to be executed by a parliament. So her anxieties are not completely overwrought. But Dominic, you asked earlier, Elizabeth doesn't want Mary publicly executed, but does she want her kind of eliminated privately? And yes, that is absolutely what Elizabeth wants. And she does want Mary kind of removed in the way that unwanted royals throughout medieval history have traditionally been eliminated. So maybe, you know, she could be drowned in a butt of mamsie or suffocated with a pillow or, you know, a hot poker stuffed up her bum. I mean, whatever. All these kind of various methods that have been used to remove unwanted members of the royal family. But she needs someone to do it. And she is kind of expect. that someone will step up to the plate and answer her needs. Because listeners may remember,
所以如果玛丽现在被处决，那么伊丽莎白的担心是，这看起来像是议会许可的。因此，议会有权进行弑君。这是伊丽莎白不想要的。而且，你知道，从长远来看，玛丽的孙子查理一世也将被议会处决。所以她的焦虑并非完全过分。但多米尼克，你之前问过，伊丽莎白不想公开处决玛丽，但她想私下里“消除”她吗？是的，这绝对是伊丽莎白想要的。她确实想以中世纪历史上不受欢迎的皇室成员传统上被消除的方式来移除玛丽。所以也许，你知道，她可以被淹死在马姆齐酒桶里，或者用枕头闷死，或者，你知道，一根热拨火棍捅进她的屁股。我的意思是，无论什么。所有这些用来移除皇室中不受欢迎成员的各种方法。但她需要有人去做。而且她有点期待，
back in 1584, large numbers of her loyal subjects, so the Privy Council, members of Parliament, particularly loyal members of the general public, had all signed something called a bond of association. And this bond had been deliberately targeted at Mary, and people who signed it had committed themselves, should Mary ever be found guilty of plotting against Elizabeth, to kill her. And essentially it had formally committed them to a kind of lynch law. And this bond of association had been bundled into the parliamentary act. So Elizabeth can say to people, well, this is now the law of the land. Why aren't people acting on it? And so this is why she is prevaricating, even once the guilty verdict against Mary has been brought in. She's essentially
有人会挺身而出满足她的需求。因为听众可能记得，早在1584年，她的大量忠诚臣民，即枢密院议员、议会议员，特别是普通民众中忠诚的成员，都签署了一份名为“结社契约”的文件。这份契约是专门针对玛丽的，签署它的人承诺，如果玛丽被发现密谋反对伊丽莎白，就杀死她。本质上，它正式承诺他们进行一种私刑法律。而这份结社契约被捆绑进了议会法案中。所以伊丽莎白可以对人们说：“好吧，这现在是国家法律了。为什么人们不采取行动呢？”所以这就是为什么即使在针对玛丽的有罪判决作出后，她仍在推诿。她本质上
hoping that one of the signatories to that bond of association will do what they have pledged to do, and quietly and silently kill Mary without Elizabeth having to sign her death warrant. What I don't understand is why, though, she, I mean, A, why it's taken so long, I mean, why have we even got to this point? And B, you know, there's sort of, oh, I hope that somebody, because of the bond of association, will privately kill Mary, you know, all this. Why didn't she two years ago say to Lord Burley, can we not just get rid of police now? like, you know, you must know
希望结社契约的签署人之一会做他们承诺要做的事，悄悄地、无声地杀死玛丽，而不需要伊丽莎白签署她的死刑令。我不明白的是为什么，虽然，她，我的意思是，A，为什么花了这么长时间，我的意思是，为什么我们甚至到了这一步？B，你知道，有那种，“我希望有人，因为结社契约，会私下杀死玛丽”，你知道，所有这些。为什么她两年前没有对伯利勋爵说，“我们不能现在就除掉她吗？”就像，你知道，你一定认识
poisoners, crack on and do it. Richard III style or getting rid of Edward II or second or getting rid of the Duke of Clarence or however, it's so easy to do. It's a great question and it's something that Mary Queen of Scots herself often pondered. So back in the days when she was able to communicate with the French and Spanish ambassadors,
投毒者，赶紧去做吧。理查三世风格，或者除掉爱德华二世，或者除掉克拉伦斯公爵，无论如何，这太容易做了。这是一个很好的问题，也是苏格兰女王玛丽本人经常思考的问题。所以早在她还能与法国和西班牙大使交流的时候，
she wrote to them and said, I think this is what's going to happen. I think I'm going to be poison. I'm going to be smothered by a pillow or whatever. This is what I suspect. But it doesn't, I think, you know, we've been casting the privy council and the Protestant establishment in quite a dark light in this series.
她写信给他们说：“我想这就是要发生的事情。我想我会中毒。我会用枕头闷死，或者其他什么。这就是我所怀疑的。”但它并没有，我想，你知道，我们在本系列中一直把枢密院和新教机构描绘得相当黑暗。
You know, they're practicing dirty tricks and operating under the radar. But they do, I think, have quite a principled sense that the operations of the law should proceed. They are, by definition, very devout Christians. And they don't want to just commit a murder below the radar. They think that justice should be seen to be done. and it's important for the reputation not just of the Privy Council, not just of English justice, but of their religion, that they are seen to be doing the right thing.
你知道，他们在使用卑鄙手段，在暗中操作。但我认为，他们确实有一种相当原则性的意识，即法律的运作应该继续进行。他们根据定义，是非常虔诚的基督徒。他们不想只是在暗中进行谋杀。他们认为正义应该被看到得到伸张。而且对于不仅是枢密院，不仅是英国司法，而且是他们的宗教的名誉来说，重要的是他们被看到在做正确的事情。
And I think that that ultimately is the reason why. And so this is why, even as Elizabeth is digging her heels in still and saying, I'm not going to sign the death warrant, Burley and Walsingham are busy scheming to try and force her hand. And so first they get Parliament to petition her for Mary's execution. and Elizabeth treats this with kind of icy contempt. And in the wake of this, Burley then thinks, well, I'm going to have to, I'm going to have to unleash the dirty tricks here. And so he reveals to Elizabeth the existence of yet another plot to assassinate her. And in fact, this plot is an old one.
我认为这最终就是原因。所以这就是为什么，即使伊丽莎白仍然坚持己见并说“我不会签署死刑令”，伯利和沃尔辛厄姆也忙于策划试图强迫她就范。所以首先他们让议会请愿要求处决玛丽。而伊丽莎白以一种冰冷的蔑视对待这一点。在此之后，伯利认为，“好吧，我将不得不，我将不得不在这里释放卑鄙手段。”于是他向伊丽莎白透露了另一个暗杀她的阴谋的存在。事实上，这个阴谋是一个旧的。
It had never gone anywhere. It had been foiled the year before. But Burley had been kind of keeping it in reserve for just such an eventuality. And even as he presents Elizabeth with the news of this supposed plot against her, He also fabricates a rumor that Spanish troops have landed in Wales. And he goes to her and say, oh, it's terrible news. You know, they're marching on Cardiff or whatever. You should double your bodyguard because you are in mortal danger.
它从未有任何进展。它在前一年就被挫败了。但伯利一直把它作为储备，以备不时之需。即使他向伊丽莎白通报了这个所谓的针对她的阴谋的消息，他还捏造了一个谣言，说西班牙军队已经在威尔士登陆。他去找她说：“哦，这是可怕的消息。你知道，他们正在向卡迪夫进军，或者其他什么。你应该加倍你的保镖，因为你处于致命的危险之中。”
And this does sufficiently alarm Elizabeth that at last, on the 1st of February, 1587, she takes the fateful step and she does sign the warrant for Mary's execution. But even now, Elizabeth remains Elizabeth. She's signed this death warrant, but she doesn't want it used. She is still hoping that someone will get in there and kind of remove Mary and it won't be in Elizabeth's name. And to this end, she has Walsingham, who is sick in bed at this time. Walsingham is often prostrated by illness.
这确实让伊丽莎白感到足够惊慌，以至于最终，在1587年2月1日，她采取了决定性的一步，她确实签署了玛丽的处决令。但即使现在，伊丽莎白仍然是伊丽莎白。她签署了这份死刑令，但她不想使用它。她仍然希望有人能进去，以某种方式移除玛丽，而且不会以伊丽莎白的名义。为此，她让沃尔辛厄姆——此时他正病倒在床。沃尔辛厄姆经常被疾病折磨。
She has Walsingham write a letter to Paulette, who is still serving as Mary's jailer. He's moved with her to fathering gay. Walsingham really doesn't want to do this, but he hasn't. no choice because Elizabeth has directly ordered him. So, Walsingham writes to Paulette that Elizabeth is very disappointed that he is yet to live up to the vow that he had made when he signed the bond of association. And why is it Elizabeth demands to know that he has not yet, and I quote, found out some way to shorten the life of that queen. In other words, Mary, do it. And Paulette, to do him credit, and I think this kind of shed lights
她让沃尔辛厄姆写信给保莱特，他仍然担任玛丽的狱卒。他随她搬到了福瑟林盖。沃尔辛厄姆真的不想这样做，但他别无选择，因为伊丽莎白直接命令他。所以，沃尔辛厄姆写信给保莱特说，伊丽莎白非常失望，他还没有履行他在签署结社契约时所做的誓言。伊丽莎白要求知道，为什么他还没有，我引用，“找到某种方法来缩短那位女王的生命。”换句话说，玛丽，去做吧。而保莱特，为了给他应有的评价，我认为这有点照亮了
on the question you were asking, why don't they just bumper off? Paulet is appalled. And he replies to the queen, God forbid that I should make so foul a shipwreck of my conscience, or leave so great a blot to my poor posterity to shed blood without law or warrant. Elizabeth is contemptuous. She dismisses Paulette as dainty. And she does not mean it's a compliment. I mean, Elizabeth is a very hard woman. But, you know, Paulette is a hard man.
你问的问题，为什么他们不直接除掉她？保莱特感到震惊。他回复女王说：“上帝禁止我做出如此卑劣的良心沉船，或者留下如此巨大的污点给我的后代，在没有法律或授权的情况下流血。”伊丽莎白表现出蔑视。她斥责保莱特“娇气”。她并不是说这是一个恭维。我的意思是，伊丽莎白是一个非常强硬的女人。但，你知道，保莱特是一个强硬的人。
But he, you know, his conscience, his faith doesn't permit him to just go around bumping people off without. due course of law. And I think that that's the explanation for why Puritans and Protestants, they think it has to be done. You know, it has to be done with God's approval, basically. But Burley now has the death warrant. And he, this is the weapon he needs. And even though Elizabeth has said, don't yet use it, he just thinks, come on, let's crack on. And so he has a little sort of cabal, doesn't he? He gets some of the privy councillors to his house and they agree, yep, we're going to do this. And they send the warrant to fathering gay. Yeah, so only the privy councillors who Burley is confident will back him in this, because they all know that they are going behind Elizabeth's back and there is the risk of considerable trouble for them once the news reaches Elizabeth. But they all think the stakes are so high, we've got to take this step. And so the warrant is given to the clerk of the Privy Council, who is Walsingham's brother-in-law, Robert Beale, the guy who had been his secretary in the St. Bartholomew's Day massacre in Paris. And Beal goes galloping northwards at top speed for,
但他，你知道，他的良心，他的信仰不允许他只是在没有正当法律程序的情况下到处杀人。我认为这就是为什么清教徒和新教徒认为必须这样做。你知道，它必须在上帝的批准下完成，基本上。但伯利现在有了死刑令。而他，这是他需要的武器。尽管伊丽莎白说“还不要使用它”，但他只是想，“来吧，让我们开始吧。”于是他搞了一个小阴谋，不是吗？他把一些枢密院议员叫到他家，他们同意了，“是的，我们要这样做。”他们把授权书送到了福瑟林盖。是的，只有伯利确信会支持他的枢密院议员，因为他们都知道他们是在伊丽莎白背后搞鬼，而且一旦消息传到伊丽莎白那里，他们就有可能面临相当大的麻烦。但他们都认为赌注太高了，我们必须采取这一步。于是授权书被交给了枢密院书记官，也就是沃尔辛厄姆的妹夫，罗伯特·比尔，那个在巴黎圣巴托罗缪大屠杀中担任他秘书的人。而比尔以最快速度向北飞奔，前往
Northamptonshire and he's accompanied by two of the greatest peers in the realm. And this is the Earl of Kent and the Earl of Shrewsbury. And the Earl of Shrewsbury is the Earl Marshall. So he's going to be the guy officially in charge of the execution. And Shrewsbury hates it because he had been Mary's jailer for 15 years and he got on very well with Mary. He liked Mary. And in fact he got on so well with her that Shrewsbury's wife, the very formidable Bess of Hardwick, had suspected him of having an fair with Mary. And so the fact that he now has to supervise the execution of the Queen of Scots is a miserable thing for him. But he knows his duty. And so he's heading off to Fotheringay as well. And also travelling from London to Fotheringay is one last key participant. And this is a man
北安普敦郡，他由王国中最伟大的两位贵族陪同。这就是肯特伯爵和什鲁斯伯里伯爵。而什鲁斯伯里伯爵是伯爵元帅。所以他将是正式负责处决的人。而什鲁斯伯里讨厌它，因为他曾担任玛丽的狱卒15年，而且他和玛丽相处得很好。他喜欢玛丽。事实上，他和她相处得如此之好，以至于什鲁斯伯里的妻子，非常令人生畏的哈德威克的贝丝，曾怀疑他与玛丽有染。所以他现在必须监督苏格兰女王的处决，对他来说是一件痛苦的事情。但他知道他的职责。所以他也前往福瑟林盖。而且从伦敦前往福瑟林盖的还有最后一位关键参与者。这是一个男人，
who goes by the name or perhaps the pseudonym of Bull. And Walsingham, who had sourced this guy, Bull, alerts Beale to his arrival. And Walsingham writes, Beal. His instrument is put in a trunk and he passeth as a serving man and the instrument is an axe and bull is the executioner. So by the evening of the 7th of February everything is in place, isn't it? And this guy, Beal, Robert Beale, the clerk of the Privy Council, he leads a delegation which has Shrewsbury, it has the Earl of Kent and it has the jailer, pour it, and he leads the delegation to Mary's quarters for this spectacular last confrontation. Yeah, and this time they do not remove their hats and for the last time personally
他以“布尔”这个名字，或者可能是化名。沃尔辛厄姆，他找到了这个家伙，布尔，提醒比尔他的到来。沃尔辛厄姆写道：“比尔。他的工具放在一个箱子里，他以仆人的身份通过，而工具是一把斧头，布尔是刽子手。”所以到2月7日晚上，一切都准备好了，不是吗？而这个家伙，比尔，枢密院书记官，他领导了一个代表团，其中包括什鲁斯伯里、肯特伯爵和狱卒保莱特，他带领代表团前往玛丽的住处进行这次壮观的最后对峙。是的，这一次他们没有脱下帽子，最后一次亲自
pulls down Mary's cloth of state. And Beal then reads out the warrant to Mary and informs her that the following morning she will meet her death on the chopping block. And Mary greets the news with great courage, there are no tears. She, many, many, contains her composure. And she swears on the Bible that she is innocent and she then requests the company of a Catholic priest for her last night so that she can give her confession and be administered the last sacrament. But this request is refused and the Earl of Kent does not hesitate to explain why. He says to Mary, your life would be the death of our religion. Your death will be its life. And this, I think,
拉下了玛丽的华盖。然后比尔向玛丽宣读了授权书，并通知她，第二天早上她将在断头台上迎接死亡。玛丽以极大的勇气迎接了这个消息，没有眼泪。她，玛丽，保持着她的镇定。她对着圣经发誓她是无辜的，然后她请求在最后一晚有一位天主教神父的陪伴，以便她可以忏悔并接受最后的圣礼。但这个请求被拒绝了，肯特伯爵毫不犹豫地解释了原因。他对玛丽说：“你的生命将是我们宗教的死亡。你的死亡将是它的生命。”我认为，
is a foolish thing for him to have said because it it confirms mary in her determination to die a martyr so people who listen to the series we did last year on mary will remember that although she's a catholic she wasn't a particularly militant catholic but now she is preparing to step on to the great stage of her own death and she decides that when she steps onto that stage onto that stage, she is going to be playing the role of a Catholic, persecuted to death by heretics for her faith. And so she sits up late into the night writing to her brother-in-law, Henry the third of France, and this is the last letter that she will ever write. And she composes it very, very deliberately, very cleverly, with the aim of doing as much damage to Elizabeth and
他说了这番话是很愚蠢的，因为它坚定了玛丽以殉道者身份死去的决心。所以听过我们去年做的关于玛丽的系列的听众会记得，虽然她是天主教徒，但她并不是一个特别激进的天主教徒。但现在她正准备踏上她自己死亡的伟大舞台，她决定当她踏上那个舞台时，她将扮演一个天主教徒的角色，因她的信仰而被异教徒迫害致死。于是她深夜坐着写信给她的妹夫，法国的亨利三世，这是她将要写的最后一封信。她写得非常、非常深思熟虑，非常聪明，目的是在国际舞台上尽可能多地对伊丽莎白和
England on the international stage as she possibly can. So she writes to Henry, the Catholic faith and the assertion of my God-given right to the English crown are the two issues on which I am condemned, and yet I am not allowed to say that it is for the Catholic religion that I die, but for fear of interference with theirs. So that's one depth charge that she is laying, which will survive her death. And all night she has been plotting other gestures of defiance. and these other gestures of defiance will be unveiled the following morning, the 8th of February, the day of her death.
英格兰造成损害。所以她写信给亨利：“天主教信仰和对上帝赋予我的英格兰王冠权利的维护是我被谴责的两个问题，然而我不被允许说我是为了天主教而死，而是因为担心干涉他们的。”所以这是她埋下的一个深水炸弹，它将在她死后幸存下来。整晚她都在策划其他反抗的姿态，而这些其他反抗的姿态将在第二天早上，也就是她死亡的那天，2月8日揭晓。
She keeps her executioners waiting. Of course she does. She's a diva. She's the star of the show. She was never going to turn up on time. And it's only at nine, so an hour after she was meant to have appeared in the Great Hall, that she turns up. And all night, carpenters had been preparing the scene of execution, building the scaffold, draping, the walls of the hall in black, draping the scaffold in the black.
她让她的刽子手等着。当然她会。她是天后。她是节目的明星。她永远不会准时出现。直到九点，也就是她本应出现在大厅的时间一小时后，她才出现。整晚，木匠们一直在准备处决现场，搭建断头台，用黑色装饰大厅的墙壁，用黑色装饰断头台。
By the time Mary arrives, the hall is lined by halberdiers. A crowd of people have been allowed in to watch the proceedings. And of course, up on the scaffolder, the executioner bull is waiting with his assistant. And both men, they wear black masks. They have long black gowns. And they have white aprons over those gowns. and Bull, of course, is holding his giant axe. Mary has dressed with great care and consideration for her final hour.
当玛丽到达时，大厅里排满了长戟兵。一群人被允许进入观看诉讼程序。当然，在断头台上，刽子手布尔和他的助手正在等待。这两个人都戴着黑色面具。他们穿着长长的黑色长袍。他们在长袍外面穿着白色围裙。而布尔，当然，拿着他巨大的斧头。玛丽为她的最后时刻做了精心的打扮和考虑。
As at her trial, she appears in the Great Hall, dressed in a flowing gown of black velvet. She has a white veil, and she has a frill of very delicate white lace at her throat. She's helped onto the scaffold by Paulette, her austere and formidable jailer, And as he helps her up, Mary says to him, this will be the last trouble I shall give you, and the most agreeable service you have ever done me. She walks across the stage and she takes a seat where she is flanked by the earls of Kent and Shrewsbury and Beale, stepping forward, once again, reads out the warrant of execution. And then it's the turn of the preacher who has been chosen personally by Elizabeth for the occasion.
正如在她的审判中一样，她出现在大厅里，穿着一件飘逸的黑色天鹅绒长袍。她戴着白色面纱，喉咙处有一圈非常精致的白色蕾丝花边。她由保莱特，她那严厉而令人生畏的狱卒，扶上断头台。当他扶她上去时，玛丽对他说：“这将是我给你的最后一次麻烦，也是你做过的最令人愉快的服务。”她走过舞台，坐了下来，肯特伯爵和什鲁斯伯里伯爵以及比尔站在她两旁，比尔走上前，再次宣读了处决令。然后轮到伊丽莎白亲自为这次场合挑选的传教士了。
This is a man called Robert Fletcher, who is the dean of, Peterborough and in fact is the father of John Fletcher, the dramatist, occasional collaborator with Shakespeare. And goodness, I mean, this is such a Shakespearean scene, the kind of the sense of tragedy about it is so strong. So Fletcher is giving his sermon, but Mary is having none of it. And first of all, she intimidates Fletcher into abandoning the sermon. And then as he begins to read his prayers, his Anglican prayers in English, Mary and the six women who are in attendance on her, they start answering these English prayers with prayers of their own, and these prayers are in the Latin of their own Catholic faith. And the voices of
这个人叫罗伯特·弗莱彻，是彼得伯勒的院长，实际上他还是剧作家约翰·弗莱彻的父亲，约翰偶尔会与莎士比亚合作。天哪，我的意思是，这简直是一个莎士比亚式的场景，那种悲剧感太强烈了。弗莱彻正在布道，但玛丽根本不理会。首先，她威慑弗莱彻，迫使他停止布道。接着，当他开始诵读祈祷文，即他的英国国教祈祷文时，玛丽和随行的六名妇女开始用她们自己的祈祷文来回应这些英语祈祷文，而这些祈祷文是她们天主教信仰的拉丁语。
these seven women's drown the sound of Fletcher, and it's completely mortifying for him. And again, he is intimidated into silence. But Mary carries on. You know, I said she's a diva. She slips to her knees and she pulls out a silver cross from her skirts and she raises it and then she begins to pray in English so that everyone present will understand what she's saying. And her prayers are for her enemies, for Elizabeth and for England. And it's incredible theatre. Very embarrassing for her executioners, of course, but there's worse to come, isn't there? And this is about what she's wearing. Yeah, so we said she dressed with great care. The time has come for her execution. And so her attendants prepare her for the chopping block by removing first her veil
这七名妇女的声音淹没了弗莱彻的声音，这让他感到无比羞辱。同样，他再次被威慑到沉默。但玛丽继续着。你知道，我说过她是个大牌。她跪下，从裙子里掏出一个银十字架，举起来，然后开始用英语祈祷，这样在场的所有人都能听懂她在说什么。她的祈祷是为她的敌人，为伊丽莎白，也为英格兰。这真是不可思议的表演。当然，这对她的行刑者来说非常尴尬，但更糟糕的还在后面，不是吗？这与她的穿着有关。是的，我们说过她精心打扮。她被处决的时刻到了。于是她的随从们通过先脱掉她的面纱，为她上断头台做准备
and then her black outer garments. And I will read from Mattingley's account. We actually began our series on Mary Queen of Scots with exactly this reading, but it always bears re-quoting. So to quote Mattingly, the black velvet gown fell below her knees, revealing underbodies and petticoat of crimson silk. And she stepped forward, Suddenly, shockingly, in the colour of martyrdom, blood red from top to toe against the somber background. And all the assembled Protestants there go into complete meltdown. And they're so appalled by this stunt, this sartorial kind of cuda teartre, that none of the official reports on Mary's death mention it.
然后是她黑色的外衣。我将朗读马廷利的记述。我们实际上是以这段文字开启了关于苏格兰女王玛丽的系列节目，但它总是值得再次引用。引用马廷利的话：黑色天鹅绒长袍落到膝盖以下，露出了深红色的丝绸内衣和衬裙。她向前迈了一步，突然，令人震惊地，以殉道者的颜色，从头到脚血红一片，映衬着阴沉的背景。所有聚集在那里的新教徒都彻底崩溃了。他们对这种噱头，这种服装上的“政变”感到如此震惊，以至于所有关于玛丽之死的官方报告都没有提到这一点。
And it was left to Mary's attendance, the six Catholic women who were there with her on the scaffold, to publicise what Mary had done. So she's there in her scarlet under robes, and she kisses her ladies farewell, and then she kneels down on the cushion that has been laid before the chopping block, and she allows her eyes to be covered by one of her attendants with a white corpus Christi cloth. And the fateful moment is now at hand. Mary lowers her throat onto the chopping block, but she continues to pray in Latin, bull step forwards. he raises his axe and he brings it swinging down and it crashes not onto Mary's neck but onto the back of her head and she cries out in agony Lord Jesus receive my soul and then comes a second blow and this time it is directly onto the neck but even now the blow isn't a clean one and bull has
而向公众宣传玛丽所作所为的任务，留给了玛丽的随从，即当时在断头台上陪伴她的六名天主教妇女。她穿着猩红色的内衣，吻别了她的女士们，然后跪在断头台前的垫子上，让随从用一块白色的基督圣体布遮住她的眼睛。决定性的时刻现在到了。玛丽把喉咙放在断头台上，但她继续用拉丁语祈祷。布尔向前迈了一步。他举起斧头，挥砍下来，斧头没有砍在玛丽的脖子上，而是砍在了她的后脑勺上，她痛苦地大喊：“主耶稣，接收我的灵魂。”接着是第二斧，这次直接砍在脖子上，但即使是这一斧也不干净，布尔不得不
to use the blade of the act rather like a cleaver to hack and saw the head clean off and even now, even in death, Mary still has two surprises in wait for her killers. So when Bull steps forward, picks up the severed head to exhibit it before the assembled crowd and proclaim the death of a traitor, this is what executioners are always obliged to do. He lifts up the head and he finds himself holding nothing but hair. And Mary's actual head shrunken and withered and gray, has rolled to the edge of the scaffold. And it takes the spectators in the hall a few seconds to realize and work out what has happened. Mary had been wearing a wig.
像用切肉刀一样使用斧刃来砍锯，才把头彻底砍下来。即使在死后，玛丽仍然为她的杀手准备了两个惊喜。当布尔走上前，捡起被砍下的头颅，在聚集的人群面前展示，并宣布叛徒的死讯时——这是行刑者必须做的——他举起头颅，却发现手里只抓着头发。而玛丽真正的头颅，干瘪、枯萎且灰白，已经滚到了断头台的边缘。大厅里的观众花了整整几秒钟才意识到并弄清楚发生了什么。玛丽戴着假发。
And that's embarrassing enough. Yeah. But then there is one final embarrassment because once Mary's sobbing ladies have been removed to their quarters and the executioners bend down beside Mary's corpse to disrobe it, again, complete mortimer. because concealed in Mary's skirts all along has been her favourite dog, a sky terrier. And this dog once detected, and it lies there amid the gore of the dog's mistress, and it howls piteously. And again, to quote Mattingly, Mary Stewart had always known how to embarrass her enemies,
这已经够尴尬了。是的。但还有一个最后的尴尬，因为当玛丽啜泣的女士们被带回她们的住处，行刑者弯下腰在玛丽的尸体旁脱去她的衣服时，又是一次彻底的羞辱。因为玛丽的裙子里一直藏着她最喜欢的狗，一只斯凯梗犬。这只狗一旦被发现，就躺在女主人的血泊中，发出凄惨的嚎叫。再次引用马廷利的话：玛丽·斯图亚特一直知道如何让她的敌人难堪，
and not just to embarrass them, but to do them the maximum harm. Well, this is the question, isn't it? Because now we've come to this climactic moment, the moment that the whole series has been building towards. Elizabeth had one of the reasons she didn't want to execute Mary Queen of Scots was she knew that it would set off a firestorm of protest in Catholic Europe, and it would make England even more of a rogue state, as viewed from Madrid, for example.
不仅是让他们难堪，还要给他们造成最大的伤害。嗯，这就是问题所在，不是吗？因为现在我们来到了这个高潮时刻，整个系列节目一直铺垫的时刻。伊丽莎白不想处决苏格兰女王玛丽的原因之一，是她知道这会在天主教欧洲引发一场抗议风暴，并且从马德里的角度来看，这会让英格兰变得更加像一个流氓国家。
And this execution is going to have extraordinarily tumultuous and fearful consequences. isn't it, for England in this struggle with the Spanish? It absolutely is because 1588, which is the year that follows Mary's execution, is going to be the year that Philip of Spain attempts to invade England, to overthrow Elizabeth the heretic queen once and for all, to restore this Protestant rogue state, as you put it, to papal supremacy, to Catholicism. because 1588 is going to be the year of the Spanish Armada. So much to look forward to. But we will be coming to the Spanish Armada much later because we will be changing the record a little bit next week, but only a little bit because there'll still be,
这次处决将给英格兰在与西班牙的斗争中带来极其动荡和可怕的后果，不是吗？确实如此，因为1588年，也就是玛丽被处决后的那一年，将是西班牙的菲利普试图入侵英格兰，彻底推翻异端女王伊丽莎白，并将这个你所说的“新教流氓国家”恢复到教皇的至高无上地位，恢复到天主教统治的一年。因为1588年将是西班牙无敌舰队之年。有很多值得期待的事情。但我们会在很久之后再谈论西班牙无敌舰队，因为下周我们将稍微改变一下记录，但只是稍微改变一点，因为仍然会有，
there'll still be some Catholic versus Protestant and the DeProsse versus Catholic action because we will be coming much further forward in time. We'll be coming to Belfast in the 1960s for the beginning of the troubles in Northern Ireland. And of course, Restis History Club members will be able to get all that series straight away on Monday. If you want to join the Restis History Club,
仍然会有一些天主教与新教、新教与天主教的冲突，因为我们将进入更晚近的时代。我们将来到1960年代的贝尔法斯特，讲述北爱尔兰“动乱”的开始。当然，Restis历史俱乐部的成员周一就能直接收听整个系列节目。如果你想加入Restis历史俱乐部，
the only way to get the full range of quite extraordinary benefits is to sign up at the Restis History.com. And of course, there will be, for those people who subscribe to the free newsletter, there will be all kinds of interesting things in the newsletter. I'll tell you one thing. I would love the newsletter to resolve. How did the dog stay quiet for so long?
获得一系列非凡福利的唯一途径是在RestisHistory.com注册。当然，对于订阅免费通讯的人来说，通讯中也会有各种有趣的内容。我告诉你一件事。我很想让通讯来解答：那只狗是怎么保持安静那么久的？
and undetected. You know, when she's kneeling down, someone's hacking at her head and the dog is still not moving, not barking, not whimpering, not making any indication of its presence. That is one of the great questions of history, Tom. I imagine that she had a little supply of biscuits in one of the pockets of her petticoats. That's my thesis. Well, if the newsletter could address that, I personally would be very, very happy. Right. On that bombshell, we'll be back next week with Northern Ireland.
而且没被发现。你知道，当她跪下时，有人在砍她的头，而狗却一动不动，不叫、不呜咽，没有任何迹象表明它的存在。这是历史上的伟大谜题之一，汤姆。我想她可能在衬裙的口袋里放了一点饼干。这是我的论点。好吧，如果通讯能解决这个问题，我个人会非常非常高兴。好了。带着这个重磅消息，我们下周将回到北爱尔兰。
and Tom, thank you so much for that. Absolutely Titanic series, a veritable tour de force. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Real Canadian Superstore has everything you need this back-to-school season. Save on lunchbox savers, like Ziggy's sliced deli-meat products for always 375. And get Life Brand Pure Vita shampoo or conditioner for $8 each.
汤姆，非常感谢你。这绝对是一个泰坦尼克号级别的系列，名副其实的杰作。再见。再见。Real Canadian Superstore拥有你这个返校季所需的一切。节省午餐盒用品，例如Ziggy's切片熟食肉类产品，仅需3.75美元。Life Brand Pure Vita洗发水或护发素每瓶仅需8美元。
At Real Canadian Superstore, when you're ready, we're ready, with a whole world and more. Hey, y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder what if, like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what-if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.ca. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在Real Canadian Superstore，当你准备好时，我们就准备好了，提供整个世界及更多精彩。嘿，大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森，来自Wayfair。有没有在网上订购过家具并想过“如果……会怎样”，比如，如果它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从Wayfair订购。在Wayfair，没有“如果会怎样”。只有你喜欢的风格和你可以信赖的质量。请访问Wayfair.ca。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。